que toujours toujours les mêmes joueuses
toujours la même chose ça continue ça
dure c'est de mieux en mieux
hélas aujourd'hui ben on va se ce
quatrième ce quatrième speech assaillent
plus que trois joueuses qui peuvent se
qualifier on parlera peut-être du
tableau un peu plus tard en gros on va
surtout voir ce que fait valentina
gouina qui pourrait prendre une énorme
option sur déjà une qualification de son
côté devant ou chez nina et on verra un
petit peu après comment ça se passe
beaucoup mais on pourrait réussir à
connaître les gagnants de ce speech s
avant avant avant la fin de cette
quatrième semaine qu' une quatrième
semaine quand même passionnante ce
serait ce serait vraiment dommage de pas
de pas avoir du suspense jusqu'au bout
faudrait peut-être rallonger un maître
mettre une petite quarantaine de deux
semaines de compétition par par la suite
mais là on pourrait on pourrait être
bloquée dès la fin de dès la fin de
cette semaine on pourrait on pourrait
savoir et connaître enfin avant la fin
de cette semaine par dont on pourrait
savoir et connaître la gagnante donc
écouter on va enfin les deux gagnantes
qui rompt qui iront jouer la finale
écoutez on va voir ça je vais vérifier
je crois qu'il ya un endroit où un ouais
alors il ya une petite erreur au niveau
de la programmation
il va falloir que vous me donniez une
petite minute j'aurai une seconde de
retard
quelqu'un qui oublie de faire quelque
chose c'est pas très grave
à
ça va me prendre ça va pas me prendre
beaucoup de temps donc on n'a pas d'eau
on n'a pas de problème on va rater
peut-être les premières secondes du
match des matches et c'est pas très
grave en soi
donc ça pas de problème il n'y a pas de
problème allez hop c'est parti
je pense qu'on est bon que je viens de
faire ce qu'il fallait faire il ya le
chat qui sont là les joueuses soissons
n'ont pas commencé
donc on est bien j'ai l'impression qu'on
est bien j'aimerais ouvrir le chat mais
tu vas tu apprends taille ce qui vient
d'arriver et diot una on va voir ce que
ça donne je sais pas si on sera très
nombreux pour suivre poursuivre
aujourd'hui
je l'espère mais mais bon salut à ma
cheese match s est ce que ça m'a est-ce
que ce que j'ai fait marche en fait
voilà c'est bon ce que j'ai fait marche
c'est l'art est ce pas exactement celle
ares alors les matchs du conte va lancer
le match moi j'avais décidé de regarder
ma joggi la rai a du retard aïe aïe aïe
aïe aïe aïe aïe
vanina ça joue pas encore on va mettre
la ce le suivi donc c'est cool on a un
peu de retard
voyez une sacrée déflation sur chasse
comme un quand je vois chase bras numéro
un est là les lots ont déflatés j'ai
envie de dire c'est terrible je pas ce
qui s'est passé mais il ya une sacrée
déflation sur czech com
du coup c'est cool j'ai réussi à
maintenir facilement entre 27 et 27,50
là les derniers jours c'est plutôt bon
signe
il n'y a pas de francophones dans la
compet non match s
du coup perd 10 ans dale ce qui est la
lune villa 14 qui arrivait aussi sa
première fois que je te vois et donc on
va regarder le match entre valides
valentina gunino contre l'état au nvm
femmes donc comme son l'indiqué
speechless féminin elle est bon on
essaie on s'essaye un peu à l'humour
échos +1 ces derniers temps alors même
si je sais que sur les autres chaînes il
aime bien mettre la barre d'évaluation
nous on va rester sans pour le moment on
va essayer d'utiliser notre cerveau les
mecs et c'est assez intéressant à faire
donc ça c'est intéressant fait c'est
parce en début de partie on peut revenir
dessus
ces variantes là où les blancs retarde
cavaliers c3 c'est pour que si les noirs
jouent aussi son puisse mettre le
cavalier en d2 et quand on jouera food
et 3 on pourra reprendre du cavalier en
c4 donc c'est cette idée là c'est pas
hyper classique genre c'est pas quelque
chose qu'on fait depuis longtemps
en tout cas c'est ça l'idée et là on a
vu qu'elle a réussi à encaisser le fou
de cases blanches valentina et moi c'est
des milieux jeu que j'ai des milieux de
jeu pardon que j'apprécie énormément
avec les blancs eux parce que
batta la paire de fois avec les blancs
et à un plan clair c'est de faire 4 et
d'ouvrir le jeu et la difficulté avec
les noirs c'est que faut que tu gardes
la position ferme et donc il faut que tu
attendes mais en gros tu as ta pas
vraiment de plan studio avait que 5 tu
vas tout faire péter et c'est pas bien
les fouilles vont jouer si tu fais rien
les blancs vont jouer aux quatre et
c'est hyper dur d'être tout le temps
prêt pour bien rencontré le 4 alors des
fois on est même juste moins bien mais
c'est généralement positions qui sont
assez pénibles là un coup comme dame b 3
peut être envisageable pour menacer ses
5es jouais déjà sur le pion bessette et
puis le 4 va arriver je trouve que
valentina a déjà une excellente position
ici alors si j'ai pas encore mis les
caméras les gars c'est volontaire c'est
parce qu'on voit là on suit un peu le
premier match ont un peu ce qui se passe
on voit un peu les scores qui évoluent
sur sur le panel de gauche
et puis comme ça après on est capable de
de changer comme comme on veut à noter
qu'il ya encore trois joueuses un an 7
dans ses premières premier quart de
finale qui joue la qualif c'est
valentine agouni naouri fans et
alexandra kosteniuk ce qui veut dire que
dans la deuxième phase dans les 2e 8e de
finale il y aura juste aucun match
intéressant il y aura que des matchs
deux joueuses déjà éliminé a donc
quelque part gens me dire bonne idée
d'avoir fait jouer tous les matchs
importants en même temps ça au moins on
est bien sûr dans le dans la deuxième
partie de match de pouvoir regarder ça
en dilettante donc le 4 qui a été joueur
je vous en parlais et là le cavalier qui
vient prendre dans ces cas là c'est
exactement ce que je vous disais qui
vient de se réaliser
et donc maintenant on va pouvoir jouer
le centre et la paire de fou côté côté
vanina côté valentina gouina et ça c'est
un bel avantage des amis pour les blancs
alors est ce qu on peut même jouer avec
petit rock on peut jouer avec grand
roque on peut jouer pour des 5
c'est une position tranquille après je
vais vous dire moi qui est l'évaluation
quand même devant les yeux je me la suis
gardé si jamais de temps en temps pour
vous la donne et on est quand même sur
du simplement +0 44 d'après cette horde
est assez faible
honnêtement moi j'aurais facilement
donner un +0 65 70 d'accord là il ya un
piège pour dams et roya foulée 80 pièges
food et de évidemment jouer la dame qui
va devoir repartir
alors du coup y'a quoi après ce
quatrième tome il ya la finale entre les
deux premières de tous les grands prix
au guide yu-na ça y est encore autre
chose quand même
je crois que ce sera lundi pour être
bien sûr très bien moi j'aurais même
peut-être fait un cinquième avec toutes
les joueuses pour bien m'assurer de tout
donc à fait fou désolé grand roque grand
roque et l'a sûrement j'imagine roye b
un tour c'est un et salue sprint
fring kling of all out
bonjour monsieur donc ouais je pense 3b
un tour ça pour un peu plus cette
colonne c'est la colonnade assez ces
quatre cadets explosive voilà on est là
avec nos petites blagues habituelles
tranquille un salut à d'autres ph oui le
retour oui monsieur oui monsieur où il
monsieur le quatrième speech s et siham
si liam site twitch williams moi je n'ai
pas l'âme si twitch salut mec est ce que
green accrochage ou encore et sahraoui
messahel à saray pas éliminé ouais donc
sarah pourra y aura quand même un match
intéressant dans le dans le deuxième
quart non surtout valentina là qui peut
peut déjà quasiment si ali ciel va
jusqu'en demies elle sera déjà la
qualitié qualifiés dont on croirait un
roi but et l'a peut-être un petit mois
voilà l'énorme j'ai écouté ce fou de
foot et si c'est là peut-être un petit
adam c'est un bon alors ça les gars on
en pense quoi du ku'damm cernant le chat
c'est un peu petit bras non au sein car
voilà typiquement le genre de truc que
je disais c'est que dès que tu commences
à te chauffe avec les noirs tu vas te
rendes f 4 5 dans la gueule et en fait
tu va empirer la situation
mais je comprends tout à fait ce que
fait les c'est pas moche ce que fait les
et est vous l'avez bon chat je peux
m'amuser à on est obligé je suis obligé
les gars je suis obligé oui mais bon
mais là c'est ces problématiques en fait
tu la position s'ouvrent et les footeux
crache à la gueule céder la main cedella
m'a fâché est très fâché ils sont très
énervé bêtement une tour en c1 tour des
indes à 24 c de l'ama très très fâché
euh ouais le classement deux points je
le mettrai tout à l'heure guillot una je
vous mettrais classement deux points les
points
c'est hyper compliqué là encore un
classement deux points
vous allez suez et salue guillaume l134
tour f1 alors pourquoi pas tour c'est un
tour d un jeu c'est pas mes tours f1
peut-être pour préparer des f-5 de toute
façon l'avantagent va papa pas
s'évaporer
k&b 6,7 un petit coup de dame b 3 voilà
on contrôle un peu le cavalier c'est
bien on attaque un peu le le pion à vii
on maintient la pression et un moment
donné ça va péter ça va lui péter à la
gueule à aller ouais il va falloir super
surveiller cette paire de fou comme
comme le lait sur le feu dans cette
partie les amis mais parce que le lait
sur le feu
c'est pas comme l'eau c'est un moment
donné ça vous est déjà arrivé ça les
gars de vous retrouver tout le lait sur
les plaques ou pas est-ce que c'est déjà
arrivé à des gens dans le chat tu fais
chauffer du lait sur le feu et le lait
et le lait se retrouvent partout
ouais ben wallace et on parle on parle
en expérience et hyper rôle où là il ya
peut-être des dames f certain qu'ils
peuvent atterrir mais bon elle va faire
d'affaires comprend elle va laisser
damev 7
elle valait s'activer hu est allé là il
va falloir faire attention à l'est la
tête elle va prendre prend la dame qui
sera d'un premier round 4
c'est chaud quand même à perdre un pion
déjà mais peut-être qu'elle c4 elle
serait active à l'ailé allez allez allez
allez allez allez allez allez les ouais
c'est chaud à dire quand même
pour un string russe elise de faire du
location c'est un jeu gas heures gratuit
bon je ferai du zoo games hub orly
sandales ce je vais pas m'embêter un tu
sais ces parages au gué soeur mais bon
c'est pas peut-être avec maxime
peut-être si maxime peut-être vendredi
on fera un stream géo gaza avec maxime
et baky bon vanina qui suis un peu un
banana qui peut être éliminée après si
elle perd ce match à la plus dangereuse
et a dû dames 7 aces et ses positions a
ses avantages blanc toulon mais les lait
d'amande j'ai envie de te dire tu sais
pas ce que ça veut dire mais je les dis
avait des fonds en invente des mots qui
a aidé 5 elle se bat elle recommence
attaquée le 3 l attaque 5
franchement elle seule ce débat bien
elle se débat très bien
elle se bat très bien
elle se bat très très bien phu f2 et
peut-être je dois tenter de prendre f4 a
maintenant tu auras toujours dftd g5
pour protéger ton car elle elle fait
d'armes b4 well échange les dames quand
même restée bien ce qu'elle fait mais
elle est toujours moins bien c'est
terrible ses positions parce qu'elle
joue bien depuis un long moment mais
elle est toujours mal ou cavaliers c3
incroyable incroyable qui a essayé trois
tours prend des 1
mais oui elle le voit aller mais voilà
mais voilà mais c'est mal et ça et tour
un airois b2 fou prend en c3 aura prend
ses trois tours prend 1,2 et jetant fils
mais c'est sa malle et j'aime ça quand
tu fais ça allait aller qui est dans le
match au cc st pal à ce qu'elle vient de
faire quelle défense de la joueuse
vietnamienne belle défense du vietnam
les amis ça fait plaisir les mecs ça
fait plaisir
et ben voilà l'enjeu qui est lancé pour
cette journée on était mauvaise langue à
dire ouais ça va être la même et où là
on l'a on a eu les on a eu les enfin
reprend reprend reprend pas ne serait-ce
pas de ce raid il est tranquille
c'est fantastique ce qu'elle nous fait
là roy b2 france et trois rois benno
grosse faute hein parce que du coup tu
donnes de pions t'aurais pu la jouer en
fait oui mon badge f1 à elle me fous g3a
assez malin ou lalalalalalalalala très
malin parce que surtout on prend et
afyon prend et le pion fils adam est
sûre pions prend elle veut fou j'ai
trois échecs
non mais tu dois apprendre et aura quand
même les lions non mais ça va très très
bien quand même pas ce que tu veux avoir
les trois pions tu crains rien en fait
avec les noirs parce que tu regagne un
tempo là dessus il ya encore tour à
trois échecs
c'est terrible le fuji trois échecs
c'est terrible c'est terrible les amis
fallait faire flasher quatre peut-être
et oui non mais elle a voulu tenter un
piège
valentina mais en réalité il ya encore
le tour à trois échecs en finale elle ça
va fair game pour les a encore un piège
tout reprend g2a oui mes pions prend
tout ranger 3 cet échec le piège ne
marchait pas
et ça fait 1 0 et ben dis-donc les amis
on ne s'y attendait pas celle là
1 quelle femme jolie jolie value mitch
jolie value me tue dans le chatt là je
dis oui là je dis oui monsieur value
mitch sagem sage être des blagues comme
ça on est on est en forme les amis
aujourd'hui franchement on est 100
mercredi le jour des enfants
c'est notre jour à nous quoi nous on est
des grands enfants les amis on est des
enfants de première de première
catégorie quoi donc on est bien mais en
plus ce soir c'est moi qui ferai la
master class avec avec fabre en sidekick
terrible terrible la masterclass orne en
plus j'ai pas eu le temps de la préparer
il ya 7 qui a eu qui a eu un contretemps
une qualification inattendue en demi
finale et du coup c'est moi qui me
retrouve avec la master class préparer
un peu à larache mais ça va je suis là
le thème ce sera le contrôle du sang
dans les ouvertures à des quatre pour
qu'on veut prendre le centre et qu'est
ce qu'on veut faire avec ce centre pour
ceux qui ont qui prennent leurs rentes
ai fait j'ai d'autres master class en
prévision un peu plus facile mais je
peux les garder pour les faire avec
avec éventuellement camel avec un
éventuellement étoiles ou d'autres ou
d'autres youtuber août witcher connu
donc je garde ça je garde les trucs un
peu plus simple que j'avais en idées
dans ma tête en réserve et
et je vois je ferai cette master class
là sur le contrôle du centre après des
quatre c'est un sujet que j'aime bien et
ce sera ce sera intéressant sans être
trop à s'en être trop compliqué non plus
on va voir une partie assez assez connu
entre koné fort gatx et puis après on
parlera un peu de philosophie et chicken
fera de la philo c'est un peu le spinoza
si tu veux c'est ça du spinoza non je
sais pas comment ce sera exactement
bon allez on reparle de cette partie on
a parlé échec on a parlé cheikh donc car
a lieu quatre ans attend l attaque 7 et
surtout preuve le cavalier prend et du
coup il ya le foot bessette qui protège
le lion donc comme ça on comprend le
coût est là elle fait un peu du bac il à
valentina bon voilà ça va en fait pour
les noirs
on fera pas du jeu gesser aujourd'hui
achats reculent patron parce que ça me
ça me fait ça me fait trop de j'ai trop
de travail aujourd'hui en fait parce que
j'ai commencé à bosser à 10h ce matin je
vais faire dix heures 23 heures quasi
non-stop
ça va bien se passer un moment donné je
suis un peu quoi non frais de peut-être
vendredi on fera du jeu gesser sharks eu
peut-être vendredi
mais nous on fera du géo gesser on
prendra le truc payant ce pas grave
enfin on va pas s'embêter un bon veut
qu'un rallye prend 1,4 des français 5
ses positions insipide allez les blancs
peuvent pas avoir davantage des noirs
non plus mais ça va jouer fond de court
ouais deux euros ça va on peut lâcher 2
euros aux gars quoi sur les routes de
russie je vais pas je vais suivre aussi
en fait mais je comprendrais les
panneaux montcaret lieu 5
ouais c'est c'est ainsi qu'à aider trois
là par contre qui est bien en d3 c'est
insipide au sein vous connaissez le
fameux joueur ainsi pilos un joueur grec
qui joue que des positions ainsi pu is à
cépie 10 on rigole un peu bloqué en d3
toujours bien placé en se structurant
bon tu dois te latella moi jamais un jeu
ce truc avec les blancs je joue souvent
tu vas avec le caillou f4 peut-être
faire f trois bombes à eau 5 peut-être
prendre prendre prendre prendre et
l'autre à une structure de merde
après une fois que j'ai le nom du bled
je peux aller sur google et chez oui les
uns une fois que j'ai le nom du bled
c'est de la triche c'est de la triche
c'est interdit à qui interdit ça
qui interdit ça c'est interdit d'aller
checker sur google le nom du bled c'est
terrible on nous coupions prend 1,5 l'an
prochain qu'il prend 2 4-d prend 4 kgs
cac40 stoxx chose et c'est times c'est
terrible alors affaire qui a eu les
trois qui est des deux c'est exactement
la vente dont je parle est un et on va
jouer sur la structure pourri bah moi
j'ai envie de dire c'est 4 juste sympa
et c'est logique de vraiment rapidement
intervenir avec le cavalier sur ce gars
là je vois pas trop ce que vient faire
le tuant ses quatre alors peut-être un
plan à trois cavaliers à 2 qui a essayé
trois qui est des cinq mais ça me paraît
long après c'est maximaliste de vouloir
mettre le cavalier en c3 parce que tu
contre leucate et des cinq mais ça te
coûte deux temps de plus c'est cher
d'alger quatre tours fc tours eu de
vrais ok c'est vrai jallet sera un coup
de faire cavalier d2 quoi elle pourrait
faire cavalier des deux est attaquée aux
quatre vents le problème c'est que tant
qu'elle attaque par quatre en fait elle
a deux pièces qui joue pas du tout ce
qu'elle est elle est emmurée quoi alors
qu'à cahier des deux elle fait
intervenir deux pièces en jeu elle fait
une synergie quoi alors que là elles
sont pas du tout en synergie c'était de
pièces elles sont en nrj 12
d'ailleurs mais bon je dois aujourd'hui
on a dit qu'on était sur les jeux de
mots ccimn nrj12 quoi c'est pas synergis
nrj12 wes ecoplus ecoplus j'assume
j'assume charcute patron genre ta
nouvelle expression c'est terrible à est
terrible cette expression je peux vous
raconter une petite anecdote que je
raconterai
bush était déjà raconté mais je leur
raconte mais quand j'étais à valence
pour aller chercher micha ya une
personne âgée qui m'a dit il fait froid
ce matin pour pour un jour d'été et
jeudi c'est terrible je suis dit c'est
terrible elle m'a regardé très
bizarrement quoi eh oui je suis derrière
c'est terrible c'est terrible donc mais
j'avais peut-être j'étais déjà raconté
l'anecdote tête tour des deux tours dès
8h trois cavaliers h4 kf3 sarraude jeu
c'est pascal a foutu elle a vraiment
deux pièces qui joue pas franchement
c'était le chaos régnant des deux fous
prendre 4 et bim tu es bien mais tu fais
jouer et on fout quelque part l'accueil
des 2 et quand le cavalier en c1 le flou
pas en fait tu t'y mobilise deux pièces
elle a très mal joué là les méens al
fekki avait libéré trois oui mais c'est
trop tard cavalli h4 kf3 les haines et
bon t'es mal les thèmes allait quasiment
quasiment un jeu de mots qui a laissé un
trou béant et la mamie espèces au début
bah ouais c'est ça en fait c'est que tu
voulais faire une synergie allait pas
aller chercher la synergie assez vite
elle s'est mis mal autant jeu parce
qu'elle fait un allin pseudo bizarre fou
h 24 11
bon voilà enfin un fou battoir
alors ils purent en c3 qui est des
dalles elle aurait eu le temps de
déstabiliser les les normands
l'avantagent ça toujours pas moins de
matos et que c'est pas fini de facile de
trouver le lien avec les noirs parce que
h 5 h 4 c'est un plan mais est-ce que
c'est assez assez rapide thouet cinq
tours h5 j'arrive bien à 1,8 ont regardé
tous rêvent sans que ça m'a l'air fort
qui est des deux tours h5n1 était
peut-être juste à temps de faire qui
avait pris un air froid puis on prend un
f3 et un tour d2 et n'arrive pas à finir
le coup là bah ouais ok c'est peut-être
son espoir tours fc entourage 5 tu as
envie de le faire marcher peut-être ça
marche pas et du coup h 5 h 4 pourrir la
colonnade très bien qui a aidé 2 qui
arrive c'est pas si simple en vrai
encore peut-être faut à ton jouet faire
tourner 5-fu g4 et dames g6 du coup
j'aime bien qui a aidé de tempo c'est
bien jouer cavalier gc un coquet halal
joue bien vanilla elle joue très bien
valentina avec les pièces noir ici on
regarde côté valentina 1 le match là on
voit qu'il ya un problème sur ce
vis-à-vis faut jouer un coup de tours
fouet f5 allez faut jouer vite la page 4
c'est bien va peut-être que ça perd tout
de suite mais je veux dire au moins tu
joues un coup quoi elle prend f3c bien
damage 2 way elle est pas mal dans le
petit jeu tactique les elle est un peu
plus faible en stratégie ouverture allez
tu revis est peut-être damache roi-dame
eux si ça les actifs toi allez c'est
bien là ce qu'elle fait elle est fichue
g4 à l'effet tour un peu bizarre toi
mais bon c'est dur de juge ou un coup à
moi j'aurais tenté le g4 est là c'est
bien joué de la part de valentina elle
va mettre la dame en d5 c'est peut-être
3h deux tours fc dur dams est très bien
joué aussi des trois têtes adam saint
calais faut jouer un coup droit je sais
tu t'attaches 5 et bien joué bon elle
est complètement ficelé avec les blancs
mais peut-être un jour tu as un père
pète tu as un truc
elles jouent des coudes vide pour le
moment mais elle peut pas faire beaucoup
plus vas-y revient sur ces 4 à elle
s'active
ouais c'est bien joué elle est très
résistante les à l'est d'alger six
échecs mais tarde pas à tour ses quatre
mandats d'amener un des mets fins et tu
m'as tu es bon belle résistance de la
joueurs vietnamienne quand même c'est
dommage qu'elle se fasse un peu trop
prendre sur la stratégie parce qu'elle
est assez forte dans le petit jeu
tactique c'est vraiment pas une
adversaire facile hein
c'est vraiment pas une adversaire facile
7les si elle était un peu plus forte en
ouverture elle pourrait être extrêmement
dangereuses et on va faire un petit
point des scores ou kosteniuk menés à la
marque les amis par bibi sahara oh la la
c'est nos joueuses là qui font le taf
aujourd'hui habib sy sarr à ses bibis ce
à quoi c'est notre bibi sarah nous
d'ailleurs même le charger faille
lapébie micha au lieu de michelle wie
micha je me suis très intéressant comme
non d'ailleurs à témoin by kevin
maintenant j'en ai marre quoi de ce nom
avec 100 le bibi devant mais bibi bibi
alexandre en sueur mais il est
exceptionnel ce bibi non il est génial
biblique stream
bon alors c'est un peu la même position
que dans la première partie et là c'est
cette structure
alors s'il vous était en f4 ce serait
khatam et là tu attends de fer tour
c'est 8
ok j'ai huit cavaliers 7 car il y avait
cinq peut être contente
mais ça pourrait jouer plus vite quand
même c'est élémentaire mon cher watson
halak a que 16 ans i begin bissara c'est
génial comme prénom bibi sarah fain je
conseille un prix ont tellement
extraordinaire comme elle a de la chance
majeure n'a pas tous d'aussi beaux
prénoms pas dit man un peu vos prénoms
là dans le chatt eu surtout des prénoms
de merde j'aurais des prénoms normaux je
suis sûr qu'ils aient absolument
personne qui a un prénom avec un bibi
devant et ça lui robin voilà on regarde
et vois c'est pas ben y vit robin by me
thibault c'est un faux prénom ça bibi
daniël vasco romaric il vous est que des
prénoms herbe zinédine baby zinedine
c'est bien au-dessus de zinédine tout
court
louis-philippe voilà bibi alex à l huile
est heureux comme bibi pascal biville
alexis vivi robin est vrai aussi mais je
l'appelais biblique m bibic fc
fantastique comme prénom
franchement c'est un beau place 1
s'appelle comment le biblique mg de
billy devant dégage
bibi vivront billy stanislas bibi
olivier believe it be by eight
bon alors c'est bien là pour les noirs 1
le plan il est simple c'est fou aux sept
cavaliers fuite cavaliers aussi c'est tu
t'appelais pions et en vrai je prends
les noirs tous les jours aujourd'hui ben
laden avait dit le plan de boue de binic
attention votre vie nique à ses très
bien en fait parce que bas les pions ils
sont complètement fixé tu avoir joué le
jeu le jeu sur gazon avec tes pièces qui
vont jouer ensemble
la valentine elle s'est fait
complètement dominé stratégiquement
alors n'est pas spécialement moins bien
mais c'est plutôt les noirs qui sont
contents du début de partie en tout cas
avec les noirs tu as largement égaliser
bibi vlad
ce serait beau coiffe habibi libye
non mais c'est bien ce truc de prennent
avec bibi devant je suis très heureux de
ça dans sa seule joueuse qui a deux
caméras c'est extraordinaire ça à
karachi à votre deux profils et deux
faces et concentre à fond mais elle mène
dans le match mais elle joue pas mal
hein 16 en 2004 et qu'elle que c'est une
espoir f5 c'est pas idiot elle veut
faire cavalier fuite qui avait lui aussi
sait plus qui est deux fois h3 or la
titre informatif ordilib et 5 ouais mais
bon elle se prend ça c'est toujours
pareil ses coûts comme f5 ça a l'air
sympa et puis finalement tu fais cba fou
prend des cinq faits abeilles à tour à
cette terrible
ben moi je serai tourbe et 8 je pense
francs b 8 ans tombé huit empire tout
rachat car les fuites ou à huit bouffées
cavalier e cissé je sais pas à l'état
jamais faux f6 donc des perdantes avec
avec 8 on prend 17 k -o ici c'est ouais
c'est terrible elle est clouée sur la
7ème elle est clouée comme ça tel un
tellement bon début de partie
elle peut jamais faire roi et fit qu'un
tour prend 1,6
bon maintenant il faut réussir augmenter
la pression parfois trois jeux à elle va
h5 bien joué le tour à 4 d'ailleurs
croit ses trois tours c4 rwc a
d'étroites on prend des quatre échecs
très bien joué tour à huit tours à 4
mais c'est ça que vous dit avec cette
les cette fameuse les ailes
elle a vraiment des idées originales
joue vraiment des belles choses
j'aime beaucoup malheureusement
malheureusement c'est un peu la pls
parfois à niveau stratégique alexandra
kosteniuk qui est revenu au score 1
contre billy sahara normalement elle
devrait elle devrait l'emporter h5
reprend des cas 3 ces deux
ça a l'air de passer malheureusement
quand malheureusement fait on aime bien
vanina de base mais on était pour un peu
de suspense quoi alors comment tu fais
pour mc clure ghg 6 3 et 6 pour entrer
dans sa mon avis faut 5 3g si soudée
qu'attaquer des quatre sur échec ça ça
n'a pas l'air beau quand même vrai nom
ça va pas peut-être tours 4 si on prend
g63 fuite a bien phu dans le cadre
d'épreuves 4.95 ariake des cats échec
encore qui est peut-être rentrer là
dedans pas si clair ouais c'est ce
qu'elle fait c'est pas si con way allons
rentrer là dedans au lait historique
si manger le pion prime steger ici c'est
en fait été ou four arrive cinq blocs et
des oeufs et du masque et prend ses cinq
quand même tu es tu as quoi de moins
t'as rien de moins moi je vous dis que
c'est pas si clair cette histoire là les
blancs il faut vraiment qu'ils à un
punch la fois qu'ils puissent punch et
parce que si fait qu'elle prend ses 5
vous cavale et pranger 5 ça peut tourner
à l'ailé b kaki étrangers 5 vous prend
ici si tu veux ok bon pourquoi pas
dommage et f5 en l'air quand même mon
laïcs et des quatre pour le moment mais
pour fc 3 g 8
et maintenant tu es tout recettes et y a
pas trop prendre et si ce à quoi que
tours 8 il y avait des fuites fou prend
un f5 am et tu vas te retrouver en elle
va se prendre une paralysie les elle va
se faire paralysée par à lille et si je
puis me permettre
et le royer dans le dans le box tu sors
plus jamais du box et et tu te fais tu
te rends fou prend 1,4 4ème 5ème 6ème
cette baisse est terrible c'est terrible
très bien joué de la part de valentina
c'est derrière
bon mais les qui fait pas un mauvais
match mais qui va être mené on va aller
voir sarah la panthère noire
jetez un oeil à sarah
bon ça joue
alors dans cette game c'est chaud allez
faut se battre on s'est complètement
foutu mais aller qui avait des f3 je
sais pas on se bat un peu marrant quand
même un qu'un amuse eacute soit des
débats j'allais pas choisir des bons
mots là se fasse battre une nouvelle
fois par monde joue le scam étonnant
quoi nexans est forte
moody tchouk hockey qui est franck et h4
j'aime ce qu'elle fait nas qui étrangers
ah je vois des speechs est féminin
toutes les semaines du coup comment ça
se passe gardin c'est un truc de ouf en
fait c'est les mêmes joueuses qui
rejouent quatre semaines d'affilée
le format est bizarre et inintéressant
donc pour été expliqués mais le fis n'a
pas d'intérêt quoi ouais ça fait très
mal ça
pour prendre ici ou là mais à tour des
salles à ton 17 36 tour des huit tours à
huit tours tours 8 maths ou alors comme
s'arrête quand moi je suis tu pourras y
fit matt est pris ce risque à pâques et
étrangers y 6 et donc c'est terminé ça à
faire 2 1
oui fans qui va gagner tranquillement
ce match sera pas tout à fait terminée
quand même y aura encore un peu de
tension
bien joué 35 et b5 le roi est dans le
carré mais il va aller prendre donc ça
c'est fait allez on va regarder un petit
peu bibi sahara qui a quand même le plus
beau tour au prénom du tournoi et qui
attaqua elle avait eu du mal contre
l'agglo je crois la semaine dernière
allaient beaucoup souffert
la tête vers b5 way pour éviter les
prises en b 4 peut-être un cahier qui
peut revenir au f5 pas d'un médecin
qu'elle peut jouer la finale
ils ont sélectionné comment il y eut des
tournois de qualification mais un p'tit
quinquin
mais oui effectivement on connaît pas
grande
je te le concède le carré des six va
être super fort un superbe locker c'est
un super bloqueurs et m'ont toujours lui
qui mène déjà 3 0 dans le match qui sert
vraiment à rien terrible pour musique
tout cas séduit 1
elle souffre
très mal autant ça parce qu'ils jouent
tous tempo ça va être difficile pour
pour la joueuse kazakh bibi g4 d'accord
c'est le coup j'aurais joué tempo
pendant f 5 mètres la tour en f1 soit c
et ku très normaux croyais froid c'est
bizarre pagtour f saint-ours f1 c'était
provoquer f4 pour essayer de faire kg 4
cavaliers f2 ou f3 qu'avait lieu 4 si on
y arrive vous mettre un pion aux quatre
un moment donné enfin faire quelque
chose quoi parce que là en fait on sent
pas avancer les pions
elle va laisser kosteniuk eu à faire un
temps g8 marche est pas encore sinon
j'aurais commencé par tour g8 avant fois
h4
mes brebis sarac qui est un peu tendre
encore 1 bat tours 4 tours c'est qu'a
très bien joué il ya une tour qui va
revenir aux huit oscars est tour trois
échecs du courage et de tours g8 ça va
partir tout seul et tours 2 bref trois
sons qui va arriver jusqu en f2 et
maintenant il va falloir terminer alors
la tourache trois fous g3 qui donne
envie même très envie
peut-être tour n'entoure détroit pour
ces deux tours 2 ouais et fou g5 ou
cavaliers français quatre cavaliers 5
qui avait lieu 3 et à tous qui gagne
c'était sûr que ça allait finir le taf
pour kosteniuk qui remporte la partie et
qui prend l'avantagé qui prend
l'avantagé de et demi un ennemi c'est
bien joué de sa part
ouais difficile un par mois je
connaissais pas toutes les joueuses
genre mumcu je connaissais pas et nine
cailloux je connaissais par les autres
je connaissais et monica ue allez 2040
coiffe un tueur au bout d'un moment pas
connaître et mouk joule
enfin tout pas mal mais j'ai artiste tu
t'intéresses pas aux trucs vraie vie ça
en difficulté
piqué un way en ahanant en difficulté on
va faire une petite pause les gars je
vais pas vous mettre la musique d en
faire juste à une pause de trois minutes
pour aller pour aller dehors sur le
balcon parce qu'il fait chaud dans le
studio donc j'allais récupérer je
préfère ne pas mettre vous ne pas vous
mettre la musique pardon parce que vous
allez suez avec la musique donc sans ça
sera ce sera mieux pour vous j'imagine
j'espère en tout cas et on se retrouve
on se retrouve dans deux trois petites
minutes a de suite les gars
à
les gars je suis de retour les feuilles
qui va arriver à 2013 comme il ya 19 70
est battue va remonter
robert fait carrément 5,8 de pause ouais
bof assez dur d'être choquant même
pendant tout le tournoi je peux vous
dire là il fait trente et quelques
degrés chez moi il fait soleil fait
chaud je comprends tu as envie de faire
deux trois heures de pause m'a aidé à
devenir dire les résultats à la fin je
rigole non en fait je rigole pas
vraiment surtout que là je suis sorti du
coup ça a réveillé micha qui voulaient
venir dans le studio il fait lourd
aujourd'hui c'est a besoin de dormir à
après moi je suis à tu as genre depuis
fait voir mars avril mai 30 60 90 ouais
moi je suis peut-être à 110 jours de
stream ou 115 jours de stream sur les
120 dernier donc ouais là là là dessus
un peu quand tu regardes ça tu suis un
peu je te cache pas mais coûte habibi
maugrée fallen surmontera les vacances
écoute je sais pas quand ce sera les
vacances pour moi et ce sera soit en
août soit en septembre où je prendrai au
moins une semaine à un moment donné
histoire de souffler un peu
ouais c'est beaucoup dans un mail en
plus il me rajouter c'est speechless
honnêtement c'est tendu et une nouvelle
fois j'aime beaucoup suivent les échecs
et tout ça mais la cc c'est dur d'être
passionné par cet événement
maintenant il faut c'est important mais
ça c'était pas prévu 4 d'avoir à 4
commenté quatre semaines de ce pitch est
féminin c'était pas prévu je m'attendais
pas il m'avait dit vas y aura peut-être
un speech est féminin cette année on
m'avait dit ça mais mais ça sera
- plus petit que l'année dernière
l'année dernière il y avait lui joueuses
ça fait quart de finale demi-finale
finale donc il y avait eu sept matchs en
tout cas évidemment mais cette année il
y aura peut-être que 4 où il y aura un
format un peu hybride mais ce sera un
petit event on l'a entre la phase de
qualification est tout à six semaines de
compétition avec 40 fois le même tournoi
quoi un petit event
c'est demain que le plus long de l'année
quoi la [ __ ] sonnette qui avait été plus
intéressante à suivre m y avait 100 fois
moins de budget je crois à peu près ça
pique un ça pique non mais en vrai sur
internet c'est pas une question d'argent
pour faire des bons formats c'est
internet c'est pas la télé ce que je dis
souvent quand les gens quand les gens me
demandent de caciques offert sa marche
sur internet ou quoi et je dis souvent
internet faut pas confondre internet et
la télé c'est deux choses complètement
différentes
sur internet c'est faux pas forcément
des gros budget quoi faut essayer
surtout de faire des trucs intéressants
et après c'est pas obligatoire d'énormes
budgets
ouais c'est vrai que l'ancien format du
speech et c'était déjà assez mauvais je
dirais qu'ils y una en soi mais c'est
vrai qu'on pensait qu'ils allaient
améliorer ils ont réussi en pire et
finalement c'est quand même à noter quoi
c'était s'était pas c'était pas facile
après je pense qu'il va avoir des
événements plus marrant là bientôt avec
championnat du monde officieux de bullet
il va y avoir quelques petits trucs
amusants et sympathique
voilà je sais pas comment s'est retrouvé
à voir ce truc là je ne sais pas à quel
moment on s'est retrouvé avec avec 7,7
et vote
je suis étonné honnêtement juste
personnellement je suis juste étonnée
après c'est comme ça
bon alors ça va bientôt repartir
ouais je vais pas je veux pas faire de
propositions de nouveaux formats guiziou
n'a pas ce que pourra l'aider prochaine
je sais pas comment on peut faire encore
pire mais on va bien trouver un et je
pense que c'est pas de chasse comme qui
organise la mais qui sont que sponsor et
au toit mais peu importe
mais peu importe et salua bibi nathan
par là les matchs n'ont pas l'air d'être
parti en tout cas moi je vois pas
repartir pause interminable c'est
terrible c'est terrible cette pause mais
sa lutte chez smat
non je ne sais pas trop et je pense même
pour les joueuses c'est pas c'est pas
évident ce qu'aime toujours le même toit
qui reprend et tout soit pas être facile
après elle gagne quand même pas mal
d'argent
j'ai plus combien gagnent la perdante du
premier tour mais je pense qu'elle prend
au moins 200 à chaque fois la prochaine
district de cap c'est pour quand bah
2021 on va pas faire deux fois le même
le même heaven dans l'année 1
alors on va voir s'il est réussi à
remonter là c'est déjà une partie
importante 1 pour les ouais c'est qui
fait suite au premier tour n'a pas être
très motivés web à une cailloux caillou
a quasiment tout je crois que tu as eu à
passer un tour et là il ya déjà 3 0 moon
jul
je crois que c'est mou zitiou qui a
peut-être passer un seul cours ou par un
seul donc pas très motivé mais jouer en
avait passé un je pense contre musique
zouk justement les elle a dû passer un
tour un moment donné mais cette fait
éliminer et bissara je crois qu'elle n'a
jamais passé un tour donc en plus haut
est sur les mêmes joueuses qui gagne
quoi c'est fou c'est terrible c'est
vraiment terrible
bon c'est genre de système de londres
hybride avec lesquels nguyen a jamais
rien obtenu
ouais en fait c'est dur ce qui a quand
même une grosse différence de niveau
entre les plus fortes et les moins
fortes entre celles qui ont été
sélectionnés et celles qui se sont
qualifiés via internet et une grosse
différence
pourquoi ils brident ce que le fouetter
angers 5 caisse assez intéressant elle a
perdu un tempo avec le fou mais elle
essaie de jouer une variante avec un
plan un temps de moins qui est bonne
pour les blancs normalement mais là il
ya un temps de moins on va voir comment
ça évolue
c'est compliqué en fait ça dépend si tu
réussis avec les nord a récupéré ses 5
tu seras mieux parce que tu auras le
centre si avec les blancs tu conserve
ses cinq ça ira tu seras mieux donc à
voir dans quelles conditions récup et
ont réussi à récupérer ces cinq quoi ça
m'arrive de jouer cette variante aussi
vrai mais je la joue différemment parce
que moi en fait elle elle fait cavalier
f3 puis fou j'ai cinq mois je fais ou g5
direct et en fait j'essaye d'en profiter
pour mac le pion à f4 puis le cavalier
en f3 en fait c'est la différence
orcl alain cavalier en f3 donc elle peut
pas le faire et bonjour lentillac bon
donc la foulée 4 avait interdit le grand
roque et le pion c5 est protégé par le
cavalier donc c'est un peu pénible les
pièces blanches commence à être un peu
toutes attachées à des choses et c'est
un peu un peu difficile
donc il ya 17 est marquée en france et 5
et ça va encaisser le lion peut écouter
ça va être pas mal dans question quand
même en c5
ça va faire du bien et on repartira on
partira après pour du cavalier des trois
échecs peut-être position est correct 1
mais plutôt pour les jets habib sy même
si elle va perdre on sait pas pourquoi
mais pour m je sais pas on sait même pas
pourquoi on fait pour que les gagne en
fait c'est un peu moche pour vanina mais
bon bref donc peut-être dès qu'il prend
ses seins qui vont arriver qu'à et qui
va s'échanger l'autre qui sera bien en
plaçant des cadres du coup mais c'est
quand même les noirs qui ont pris le
centre court avec les pions de 4 des 5
es là qu'ils allaient prendre qu'à elle
prend dame prend kébé trois dames c'est
cette dame sept mois j'aurais plutôt
partie rassuré plutôt partie ans et 7
mais ça va mais bon t'as pris tout
l'espace tu peux prendre de faire
cavalier ou cinq qui a aidé trois ici
dans l'idée fait cavalier 5 direct c'est
exactement la même idée mais regardez le
temps aux siens c'est une énorme
domination fou prend au droit prend à
eux deux dames f5 et peut-être qu'à
valider 3 maintenant ouais ça à ta cave
de s'attaque b2 s'attaque tout et puis
on prend pions prend qui prend b2 qui
est privé de directs et c'est une
nouvelle fois terminée la dame 17 bien
joué ces menaces d'un bep cinq échecs
breedam b5 dame prend b3 la sai et
valentina qui commence à prendre
l'impact psychologique car y aura encore
g5 il faudra trouver une défense mais
mon pire dams et 4,1 à pardon j'ai cinq
dames c4 et si on échange équiperont et
qu'elle prend jugé 6 h à 3 h huit
caisses assez au pire si tu sais pas
comment faire tu as toujours ça mais
c'est peut-être très bien d'ailleurs un
jeudi le pire mais ce n'est pas du tout
le pire hein
ce que le truc c'est que sur dame
pranger cinq dames c'est katia padam 5
ont accueilli des trois ans j'avais vu
mais comme elle met du temps à jouer
ouais ce qu'elle va faire pourquoi j'ai
h6 et f6 mais bon bah ça c'est ça va
aussi à elle et qui commence à tourner
way exactement quand sa tournée du
mauvais côté qu'elle est 3g trois
peut-être dams et 4 dames baidoa
tourache si c'est pas mal joué c'est
bizarre de parapher dame c4 pour
échanger c'est étrange ça ok c'est bon
ça doit complètement aller pour les noix
encore jean retour des six noms prestige
et 5
ok c'est plus si claire clerc 36 g 5
oui mesdames c'est casse c'est tellement
évident comme coup je comprends pas en
fait dame b 2 tu as une pièce et des
pions plus pourquoi tu t'en beta à
vouloir gagner de manière pareil juste
tu dois aller chercher la partie en
échangeant les pièces mais ça c'est vrai
que ça peut être un point faible
bref airwatch deux peut-être mieux même
que rush 3 les filles sont peut-être
parfois un peu moins en contrôle et
tourcoing f6 maintenant c'est incroyable
3e set il ya peut-être dames 5 juste
assez incroyable les amis la partie qui
a tourné et la tour prend g73 f4 s'est
terminée un difficile de perdre une
pièce de moins comme ça mais assez bien
fait en fait c'est pédagogique elle a
voulu continuer à jouer pour mater
valentina et quant à une pièce de plus
et une position écrasante
tu dois tu dois absolument échanger les
dames et finir la partie pas tu ne dois
pas gagner comme ça quelquefois c'est
pour moi c'est une faute professionnelle
pour pour un grand maître de faire ça
c'est grave erreur c'est grave erreur de
faire ça tu peux pas d'âme c4 s'était
changé d'âme force et à une pièce de
plus et ton adversaire à 0 activités et
au lieu de faire ça tu laisses toute
l'activité à ton adversaire
j'ai sous-estimé contre eux je ne sais
même pas du conte rejouer en fait c'est
que tu as une pièce de plus et à bobigny
qui te dit
quant à une pièce de plus tu ne dois pas
gagné une partie une deuxième fois et
surtout que là c'était une pièce de plus
vraiment très net où t'as pas peur que
la finale soit dur à gagner
des fois tu as des positions tu as une
pièce de plus ce gars a déjà deux pions
et tu te dis si je simplifie trop il
peut revenir ça peut faire nul tu peux
avoir peur là c'était une pièce de plus
nettes simple précise facile je trouve
que c'est grave
après chacun pense ce qu'il veut un vrai
manque de pragmatisme
on va souvent chez les jeunes - chez les
grands maîtres exactement qui est
d'investir talent c'est quand je faisais
dame c6 bogoliubov et je ramenais madame
en défense et j'avais plus aucun
problème
j'avais quand même vu dame b 6 brest et
du troll peut-être bon alors le pion u6
et indéfendable ah si adam b6 si adam b6
sa patte a pas de choix en fait
parce que qaïs et 5b 4 c'est ce que je
voyais et pousser 5 des quatre aussi
ou alors elle va tenter un truc comme ça
c'est hyper intéressant ça à laférois
jeu suite à un simple puis on prend et
des cats étaient hyper intéressant avec
l'idée sur dame prend fou c5 et des
quatre marchés pas direct puisque dame
prend aussi c'est sûr échec d'où l'idée
de 5 des quatre c'était hyper
intéressant tracé dommage qu'elle n'ait
pas vu je pense que c'était bon on fout
des trois taureaux ricard et deux
peut-être fou des six maintenant car il
y avait fuité ces trois fous des six
bon écoute et les amis
c'est bien pour les blancs la case de 5
est fixé et on va pouvoir attaquer à
l'endroit alors bekkat je comprends pas
trop elle veut peut-être éviter ces cinq
mais c'est un peu bizarre à 6 aussi le
truc c'est que les blancs doivent jouer
de ce côté là je pense m'être une tour
en 1 1 pu ranger 4 qui avait les anges
et 3es et jouer pour g5 qui avale et h5
peut-être qui c'est bizarre que les
noirs frise aussi la dame a ok elle
frise pas elle veut rentrer sur la
colonne harel veut faire à bab tour à 2
je pense qu'elle doit faire d'un f7
d'accord mais juste faut que tu rentres
un jour je pense sur la colonne à quoi
que de toute façon ça être al'avantage
des blancs si le jeu se cantonne à ce
quart d'échiquier 1
on voit qu'ils allaient faut braquer il
ya le cavalier qui va revenir vers eux
cinq machin g5
non c'est très problématique qui est si
ça peut faire j'ai trois pour blinder le
pion et préparer l'arrivée du cavalier
pourra reprendre de foe 5 et jouer avec
la paire de fouilles sur le rock
à ce soir sprint kling cloud
d'un f2 peut-être f5 qui va arriver
une autre possibilité un on va peut-être
faire j'ai quatre quand même ah mais
j'ai quatre épreuves quatre pardon faut
pour un f4 qui est pro f 4 ça pas mais
j'ai quatre cas les problèmes
4 pranger six bons alors tu fais j'ai
trois cavalières 3 qui est aussi simple
qu'on voulait faire juste avant c'était
logique ça bizarre ce qu'elle fait
vanina
cavalier f3 lancia bab tour à deux quand
même pas une idée depuis tout à l'heure
pour venir embêter quand même un peu les
blancs en plus de 37 secondes pour la
joueuse vietnamienne dans les autres
matches music uk ce qu'elle va remonter
à bibi sahara qui remonte à bibi sahara
qui revient et ses séries comme match
vivi sarah étonnant là elle perd trop de
temps les à bab tour à deux c'est quand
même logique ou partir pour autre chose
elle doit réfléchir à kayes prend 1 kg 5
stelly des dames c'est cette il ya fou
prend h7 qui va arriver
l'andam h4h six appareils père dangereux
ça là il ya les deux fous qui sont qui
sont qui ont les yeux rivés sur le roi
adverse et ça al'air salaire très
compromis pour la joueuse vietnamienne
mais bon si si valentina trouve rien de
précis ou tel échange tempo et dams est
maintenant non et dams est ce pareil
super s parent s est super fort ça
faisait un clouage et la sueur g3 le
veut quoi il a plus de quatre son
cavalier c'est dommage il y avoue
pranger si ça l'a pas vu
elle n'a pas vu le hockey prend h 4
olala extraordinaire les amis auxquels
niveau de jeu dans dans ce premier tour
oh c'est du jamais vu ça oh c'est
terrible oh c'est terrible c'est
terrible kg ci de donner une pièce en un
pas vu qui prend la dame au assez
extraordinaire les amis c'est pour ça
qu'on aime ces tournois
oh c'était niveau de jeu 8 censure sur
les soldes battles a assez rarissime de
voir une série de coups de pareils même
avec peu de temps à la pendule les amis
c'est extraordinaire c'est
extraordinaire les amis ouais c'est
vraiment pour ça qu'on veut voir ces
compétitions
moi je veux te ça pendant quatre
semaines et je voudrais commenté que les
fans partie en fait
ouais c'est extraordinaire c'est
extraordinaire je m'y attendais package
et 6 ne pas voir flou pranger 6 l'autre
qui le fait pas et car elle y prend dame
c'était pour les amis ouais c'était très
beau ac c'est magnifique ah c'est ça
qu'on aime les gars c'est ce genre
d'enchaînement elle est là elle joue
plus dans mon style elle réussit à
mettre un peu le truc en place les avez
là c'est beau quand même assez
extraordinaire
je suis content de de la fin de partie
précédente là je suis refait là à faire
un truc bien là aujourd'hui
ça fait plaisir à ça fait plaisir
moi je suis content on va voir ce qui se
passe dans cette partie mais bon il y en
a marre de parler des petits trucs
stratégique de qu'on en fait on s'en
fout ça va faire des cbc car elle essaie
cachait pas qu'elle fasse gaffe de
passeront un fois ci ce relou un moment
donné mais même les profondes et font
des fautes de débutants pas
non mais c'était cool ah je revois une
forte parenté f 6 kg 6 bon ta tour
attaqué mais tu le vois pas tu fais d'un
rêve cinq attaques lecavalier et tu
franck cavallier e set pour être maranon
mais les mieux tu as toi attaquent et
tuent et tour des huit tu te prends
cavaliers ou 7 ça peut être une variante
marrant de ça on a espoir damage 5 bien
joué non mais les peut l'emporter 1 les
peut l'emporter les amis tout est
possible tout est possible
f5
ok c'est bien ce qu'elle fait parce que
sur f tout reprend g6 ya tant
qu'étranger six attaques la dame qui on
prend l'eau justice contre attaque et
attaque mais d'un projet six échecs
s'empara de la dame auquel appris de la
dame je pensais qu'elle prendrait de la
tour c'est pareil c'est quand même plus
intéressant de ramener la tour pour
faire une attaque latéral et préparer
l'arrivée de l'autre tour c'était plus
intéressant je pense
elle a perdu le bénéfice de sa bonne
ouverture je pense à l'est
la tour en f2 ça va quand même
ça va quand même
bon taf si c'est un coup ici je lisais
carilli g6 damev 5e set
trois petits tours ici à et tour c'est
celle ci qui a aidé 6/3 6/4 et l'ibsr
tomber cet ours et un pour les blancs
d'ailleurs c'est la partie mais la fetwa
f 18 qui doit être meilleure et h4
qu'elle veut h5 les retours super beats
demain au nom je pense pas on a laissé
se composait le super blitz surtout au
gabon par mon grand chose de prévu
demain
bon position est pas clair moi je
prendrais les blancs parce que j'aime
bien voir les cavaliers en bis sur
lequel je peux peut-être le maire angers
3e de ces trois sphères déchets 4 un
moment donné bon je sais pas qui j'ai
trois tours f4 aussi je viens kg 3 en
fait elle a le temps plus les
j-3 ça a l'air sympa je passe qui la
gêne
parce que tu attaques un pion quand même
maintenant réfléchir à quelque chose
d'autre
3h de jeu serait toujours corriger 3
pour attaquer le pion
ouais bien jouer et maintenant peut-être
tour f 4 chiens j'aime bien aussi je
trouve que les noirs ont pas trop de
plans tu veux cavale yeux deux
cavalières 4 aussi qu'elle a retenté une
fourchette mais c'est pas passé on va
revient à angers trois entités bien elle
fait gaffe de pas de prendre tour ces
deux as et peut-être au loup ça me
revient
c'est un peu bête d'or fait ça quand
même autant nous référons à g iii roi f4
faire hyper attention sur moi j'ai trois
fois 6 3 f 4 tours f1 ont plus de 20
secondes pour bounine assez chaud et roy
g3 faut jouer plus vite là c'est pas
fameuse qu'elle fait un mais bon elle
veut roi g3 est roi f4 et pas se prendre
pour f1 - le voit quand même des trucs
non non c'est bien ce qu'elle fait allez
je mise sur une victoire de l'est les
amis plus que 7 secondes pour valentina
vois la tour qui vit en c2 au ces choses
c'est chaud patate pour ses sets 3 6 kg
7 3 et fille de bien jouer pour ses
vitraux à vii pour ses sets ça va faire
un nul ah non pas deux nuls
alors y'a pas tout reprend j'ai cet
échec
roy f4 a laissé bien tenté tour ici
voilà plus de temps là les allées ouais
ok là elle est venue prendre le pion à
l'est des cinq des six noms fouache 5,3
f2 aller le pion des les amis à les
fonds envoyés de pions délégua
paraissait bien sa cavale et f5
maintenant à l'ailé au nom elle va
tomber
oh non elle est lente qu'à relief ça que
c'était le coup d'avant oh là là comment
ce battle aura le coup d'après à elle a
joué avec un coup de retard elle avait
la bonne idée mais avec un coup de
retard assez dommage
c'est dommage pour la joueuse
vietnamienne elle a trouvé le bon truc
mais à retardement
c'est terrible ouais c'est terriblement
dommage c'est terriblement dommage
ouais c'est horrible l fallait faire des
cinq plus tôt elle a perdu deux temps à
faire n'importe quoi
elle a perdu de temps à faire n'importe
quoi et c'était trop tard après égalité
dans ce match toujours trois partout
c'est serré c'est tendu les amis le
match et le match est tendu peut pas
dire que ni l'une ni l'autre des
joueuses pour le moment ne soit au
dessus on a senti une petite force côté
valentina ouverture milieu de jeu on
avait senti les un peu plus forte en fin
de partie
finalement ça c'est un peu un peu remis
mais le match est très serré dans les
autres matches ohana musi tout qui
remonte
oui fans qui s'envole à 6,0 et kosteniuk
eux qui mènent toujours 3 2 on peut
jeter un oeil kosteniuk on à l'échiquier
à 4,2 maintenant dont kosteniuk qui va
avoir match gagné
moody tschupp tourner jul de toute façon
elles sont toutes les deux déjà éliminé
de la compétition donc c'est un match
qui a à proprement dire absolument zéro
intérêt sportif est donc le seul match
intéressant ici c'est le match de vanina
contre les essais celui qu'on est en
train de suivre ensemble
en direct alors la tour qui vient en d1
en face du cheval cette f4
elle va vouloir jouer avec beaucoup de
conviction a les droits valentina voir
ce que ça donne un côté la structure un
peu délabré mais quand même elle a un
cinq contre quatre a les droits à faire
valoir
rocard il ya deux fous et 7
et alors là tours qui varie vendée 8 par
la suite alors voir ce que ça donne les
amis mais ça lui a fait payer le moko
dans le chat par les sandales libye
valentina bibiana bibi alexandra ans sur
toutes les trois bill est aussi un
enfourner deux peut-être kaïs ces cinq
es14 peut être une idée à sainte gemme
bien fou un cas et c5 est ok elle
s'active un peu p 3
peut-être b5 ici un pour faire péter le
pion b3 peut être une idée ça peut être
une vraie idée les amis elle a fait tous
rêvent dé 8 qui a un coût aussi 1h 3h 6
d'accord elle se garde une petite case
pour pour le fou ça jamais fait de mal à
personne
il va falloir mettre la pression
[Musique]
tour des quatre qui a été joué j'avais
pas vu parce que j'ai pas eu le petit
son puisque le bessin qui est
intéressant quand même
ce bessin qui va intéresser quand même
ce que pas fou prend pardon je comprends
qu on prend fou prend qui est prend b3
pour prendre des huit on prend des buts
mais ça a l'air cool quoi tu as gagné un
tempo sur la tour et tu as ton pions
passé à jeu pas là jamais décidé de le
faire
mais sur quelle prend b3 c'est quoi son
idée j'arrête l'ordi damned
y'a rien ok mais bon là les traumas
l'otan elle a pris trop de temps surtout
à les pousser 5 tempo là a laissé bien
elle va faire tout reprend tout reprend
manquer ce cas ce qu'elle est en tout
cas t-il à double tranchant en fait les
isséens dame b6 elle s'en prend aux
points 3 mais là je pense qu'elle a pris
l'avantagé maintenant fou pro 3 où il ya
le gagnant un pion et bien jouer il peut
y avoir des fous j'ai un échec pénible
en plus avec des casses g3 qui s'ouvre
mais elle est très mal autant mettre la
dame en d4 je pense food et 4 c'est pas
facile à jouer avec si peu de temps sur
la pendule sur pareil quand sur f5 ya
toujours des idées avec des fous pour
eux cinq échecs enfin deux variantes
genre qu'il prend des 3 way fg six
prises cinq est prise à un an ou
cavaliers f4 marie cavallier f4 mieux
elle joue bien l'aller elle a de nouveau
la position gagnante 1 il ya une phase
très tactique dans la partie elle en est
sortie devant elle un peu le même défaut
que moi tu vas être trop mal autant en
voulant jouer trop principal mais bon
ses deux pions de plus position
écrasante avec avec plus de seconde d'un
crémant j'aurais donné un grand avantage
au noir mais le plus un il est très sale
normalement c'est dur normalement c'est
dur alors que baby saran revient elle a
encore gagné une partie contre kosteniuk
elle sort son match suivi sarah
valentina
qui réfléchit et qui se met sacrément
mal autant bon dur à jouer il ya d'amd 2
qui arrive elle empêche dams et 3 très
bien joué avec si peu de temps force les
change quasiment des dames et maintenant
la finale je pense qu'elle a prévu que
j'ai 5
bref c'est bien joué elle va essayer de
près move alger alger elle remonte un
peu autant elle joue super bien là
la joueuse vietnamienne a peut-être kg 6
soit ok et des cinq cavaliers ou cinq
doit être prêt move un peu qu'ils aient
des sept cavaliers affichent 6 kg et six
cavaliers 4 c'est bien cavalier e set
qui est des cinq est ce qu'elle fait là
il faut f6 j'aime bien mais à cinq qui
tombe à elle c'est mal organisé
les ok c'est son autre défaut elle sait
pas trop bien placé ses pièces en finale
andy ait note déjà dans la finale
précédente elle a fait l'erreur de ne
pas avoir poussé le pion assez vite et
du coup oui on voit que c'est son défaut
bon là il ya eu un petit lac de notre
côté ça les change pas elle veut la
faire tomber c'est sale c'est très sale
mais après c'est d'être drôle
y a personne qui peut gagner la
proposition de nul et c'est nul
restait tendue les amis alors est ce qui
a encore une partie dans la cadence en
tout cas vanina qui wayne on ya plus de
temps ces films qu'on va les voir bibi
sahara on va jeter un oeil au score
alors le score qui a enflé un côté ou
ifan musi choo qui est menée 4 2 qui
sera sûrement éliminer une nouvelle fois
et kosteniuk qui a pas qu'il ya pas la
partie facile contre bibi sahara ni visa
qui fait son match
bibi mumcu le qui va de nouveau éliminé
une joueuse de haut rang la sara black
panther je crois qu'il avait déjà
éliminé kosteniuk musou parlons de
mémoire ce terrible un point positif de
sortir deux fois contre mu joue quand
même
ouais c'est chaud bam c4 maintenance
avec les tchats en anglais des chaînes
des chèques en ce moment ça donne quand
même l'impression d'avoir weddi dix ans
de moyenne d'âge ou 11 en quoi c'est
terrible après c'est bien ça fait
beaucoup de gamins qui débutent les
échecs mais à
mais c'est vrai que j'espère que ça ne
viendra pas comme ça en français après
sera aussi à moi la petite personnelle
de gérer le truc pour que ça devienne
jamais comme ça parce que ceux enfin j
arrivais plus j'arriverai plus à stream
est en fait il ya un moment c'est pas
chargé par agip à gg pas 12 ans quoi
sachant jambes et cinq bons sur la même
chose un singe sur la caste des 5 voir
ce qui se passe dans cette partie mais
on est surtout sur le match de l'es1 et
quand même ou un bibi sahara qui sort
quand même son match aux siens elle a
peut-être talent des cinq thématiques
elle avait bien joué un très bien joué
de la part de bibis sarah elle a réussi
à faire le dessin qu'il ya la tour en
ligne de mire en plus que j'avais pas vu
de base donc là ça va faire un dame b 8e
fois d'amd 8
qu'est ce que c'est que ça non mais
c'est quoi ça 1 elle veut prendre en c1
après faire ça oui non désolé j'avais
pas vu c'est logique
j'avais pas vu la tour c ans à la fin
basse est difficile de naviguer d'une
partie à l'autre après un adam v8 ça
paraissait tellement fort mais ça aussi
remarqua
la tour est menacée en des 8 faut il
trouver une case
on va au tour j'ai vite fait tellement
peur il faut ensuite m'attendre à cette
dérive parce que c'est lui qui était
très malin juste beavis araki qui a fait
n'importe quoi là on la fin de partie
c'est terrible difficile à ce qu'à la
scala raté donc on peut repasser on va
refaire une petite pause je vais
repasser cette partie là en entier de
toutes façons le match intéressant sera
celui entre valentina gouina et les uns
c'est le sait le match le seul match
vraiment serrée va être causé new
qu'elle va gagner en bullet c'est sûr
elle est beaucoup plus forte
je donne pas beaucoup de chance à habib
sy mai mais le match de valentina
contrôler ça être intéressant donc je
vous laisse sa place est parti en replay
on se retrouve dans trois petites
minutes a de suite
à
les amis je suis de retour pour pour le
pour la section bullet on va se mettre
les calmes
c'est à ce moment là qu'on décide de
mettre les câbles les gars alors
valentina gunino
on la trouve on met la cam immédiat mal
voilà valentina qui est là en gamme
un élève c'est valentine à
et du coup les on va la récupérer par
ici elle est là on va dégager l'autre
calmes et voilà on aller et on va se
mettre on va se mettre côté les du coup
c'est pas encore reparti on va ne plus
suivre valentina et on va suivre les les
qui peut être parti pour une pour une
belle surprise les a mis dans ce match
aller les qui envoient des 4 l on va
rejouer son système avec un relief trois
fous g51 enfouis f4 le vrai système de
londres joué par parler qui voilà qui
retarde la poussée du pion peut-être
pour jouer ces quatre noms pour jouer
ces trois le foot hier par angers toaff
ou des 3l a fait sa petite pyramide et
le cavalier qui arrive en a eu cinq donc
une position théorique du système de
long le cavalier qui est là est
peut-être allé f4 pour maintenir le
cavalier f6 damage 5 ça ça peut être des
choses qui font très mal en bullet les
qui décide de prendre 17 c'est un petit
peu étonnant et peut-être joué avec
cavaliers f3a maintenant pour pour jouer
avec grog carrément aller petit rock
joué quand même
elle appelle la flexibilité peut-être
fou mais cinq cavaliers ou 5 1 peut
toujours être une idée pour visser sur
cinq non elle ne fait pas ça échange en
g3 peut-être le fou b5 toujours
intéressant il ya aussi car a lieu cinq
qui peut aller les blancs qui ont le
contrôle un peu meilleur du centre et
qui ont la petite attaque avec dame b3
sur le kazakh est regardé si vous
comparez les cavaliers way le cavalier
blanc qui avait la priorité de la case
e5 si les noirs jouer si j'imagine dam
des trois de la part de l'est pour
menacer peut-être un matin à l'est les
dames c'est de il va falloir qu'on
recalcule et f-35 d'un match c'est 3f
cette 3e 5
ça semble pas passer les qui a peut-être
perdu un poil de temps avec son attaque
allait damage 7 sa part est 3e 5 et
tours 3 allez il faut il faut tout
tenter maintenant elle a été un peu
elle est un peu lente en milieu de
partie l'est mais la position reste très
complexe maintenant avec une tour qui
arrive en d4 en f4 aller il va falloir
maintenant pour les produire son effort
dans cette danse est parti
et rapidement ramené la laque tour sur
la colonne f le problème c'est que plus
tu réfléchis ici plus tu donnes du temps
à ton adversaire pour respirer pour
inspirer pour reprendre son souffle et
ce qu'on veut ici aux côtés côté
vietnamien s'est justement que
l'adversaire ne prennent pas le souffle
aller il va peut-être falloir prendre en
prendre un f5 deux fois c'est une option
tour g4 aussi les amis autour g4 paraît
intéressant avec l'idée de prendre 5
puis prendre g7 éventuellement la
joueuse vietnamienne qui a de la tacc
mais qui est trop lente un vraiment
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup trop lente
elle a bien offert vingt ou trente
secondes de réflexion à son adversaire
allait bim g4 on attaque le cavalier
dame pranger cette tour f 8 non elle le
fait pas ouais c'est dommage elle va
pouvoir s'entendre mordre les droits de
les doigts pardon de ses secondes
perdues pour rien finalement
mais aller d'un proche si j'ai peut-être
des dames f6 dame 3,5 et la marée de
pions un qui peut arriver sur valentine
agouni nadal j'ai six salles attaque le
pion le pion est protégé dame g5 allait
peut-être une dame en f4 il semble quand
même qu'elle ait laissé passer sa chance
la joueuse vietnamienne dans cette
partie et que valentina gouina va
réussir à faire l'écart des coups comme
des quatre peuvent arriver à tout moment
le roi qui par machettes la tour en d4
alejo f2 qui défend plus que 9 secondes
allez la dame qui peut repartir vers là
haut
damages cinq dames f3 peut-être dans me2
dam des trois la dame qui va couvrir g3
qui va attaquer f5 a laissé bien joué
côté côté vietnamien
la dame qui vient en d3 menace d'armes
probable 5 maintenant il va falloir
défendre la défense c'est l'attaqué pour
la joueuse russe mais la dame en h2
meyer genre de statu quo aller qui
réussit à mettre la pression maintenant
allèles dame elle va laisser ouvrir la
colonne c mais en contrepartie elle va
essayer d'ouvrir le roi allait peut-être
comme à 5 maintenant elle elle envoie
l'attaqué ou la la la la tour c'est un
sa menace d'alger a ouai c'est dommage
côté les d'avoir laisser ouvrir cette
colonne c est connecté la dame et la
tour sur la première rangée c'est quand
même une erreur assez grave et c'est
dommage mais je pense que la faute
n'avait été commise à ce moment de la
partie mais peut-être plus tôt au moment
où tous les 2 v de v devait jouer pour
pousser de dam dam des trois beaucoup
plus rapidement et maintenant valentina
wii minna prend l'avantagé elle mène 4-3
et il semble que ce soit déjà une balle
de match pour la joueuse russe puisque
la partie
duré assez longtemps on a du mal à voir
plus de trois parties dans cette
séquence dans cette cadence donc balle
de match pour valentina et les qui
pourra vraiment vraiment sans s'en
mordre les doigts
les doigts les doigts de l'est donc le
fougueux en d6 un peu le même système
elle va réattaquer leroy fo qui allait
avec plus de conviction la halle et
peut-être fou prend direct et dames b6
dame v8 jouer ça va échanger en d6 la
dame qui remit un déca talent et en
échangeant le cas tomber de cavaillon f6
et on joue une partie longue côté côté
les alors si tu veux vraiment voyez tu
fais grands requins avec l'idée de faire
g5 g4 non elle en voit pas ça manque
peut-être un peu de conviction côté côté
les qui pourrait qui pourrait envoyer un
peu plus violemment sur le roi allait
tourner un âge si jouer fou des trois
dames dessins qu'elle attaque le pion à
deux et peut-être un coup comme le
simple nom maintenant il y aura une
ouverture de la colonne eux et ce sera
un problème elle mais la tour ont des
huit tours 1 à 6 avec l'idée peut-être
de b5 et c5
la joueuse la joueuse vietnamienne qui
qui a des convictions dans cette partie
peut-être ces cinq sur qui on prend et
adam prend des 1 mais juste ça manque un
peu de vitesse une nouvelle fois un
c'est un petit peu ce problème qu'elle a
eue pendant tout le match c'est de
manquer de peps en milieu de jeu a
laissé cinq pôles envoyait elle perd
elle perd du temps sur des coûts
vraiment logique et c'est là dessus que
gunino va construire sa victoire 1
malheureusement l'on ne peut pas gagner
une partie sur un coup mais on peut la
perdre et c'est ce qu'est en train de
faire les en fait elle fait rien de
spécial elle fait rien de mal ou de bien
mais elle perd juste du temps du temps
du temps du temps et elle a déjà plus
que 20 secondes et malheureusement on a
du mal à s'enflammer parce que les en
train de tout donner j'ai envie de dire
je vais passer le premier tour du du
speech est féminin vanina mahdi l'ailé
la lie à [ __ ] un f5 et tout reprend
1,8
c'est terrible hein alors a vraiment
fait une non partie ouais un niveau de
jeu vraiment déplorable dansez dansez
bullet côté les ça et c'est moche c'est
très moche qui c'est ce qui s'est passé
allait elle elle a réussi à récupérer le
plomb mais maintenant dams et de damages
set et ça va faire très mal à les lie à
tour f1 et la dame allait elle encore
des cas dans la case h4 mais c'est en
train d'arriver de partout elle défend
la maintenance urgent et 3 qui est
proche trois rois g2 on avait
l'impression que c'était déjà fini mais
voilà c'est fini maintenant
gwennyn à tout temps tout en contrôlera
g2
cavalier a attaqué la dame et attaquer
toutes les pièces noires sont attaqués
il va falloir trouver un coup ici pour
les dames g7 mais maintenant il va y
avoir droit prend h3 alors là quasiment
intérêt à abandonner tout de suite et
espérer jouer encore deux parties même
si ça paraît ça paraît difficile le
temps le temps s'égrène quand même et et
vanina tout en douceur qui réussit à
mettre à mettre l'écart à mettre la
différence affaires à faire l'effort au
moment où il faut ces abandons pour les
mais ça va être une perte du match
finalement un match qui était équilibré
et on sait on sait à quel moment à quel
moment elle aura raté le match on le
sait on le sait ce sera dans l'est dans
les milieux de jeu dans les débuts de
milieu de jeu qu'elle aura qu elle aura
laissé laisser filer le match et qu'elle
l'aura perdu
bon c'est toujours dommage mais bon là
maintenant il n'y a plus a plus vraiment
de suspense et en plus être partie là
est parti pour durer
on va jeter un oeil maintenant sur les
autres matchs sur les scores à on va
aller voir be by sarah bibi sarah 6,5
allez il peut y avoir une surprise côté
côté bibi sarah on va aller sur ce match
puisqu'à qu'un point d'écart ça doit
être la dernière partie du match entre
les deux femmes est donc la joueuse casa
qui peut nous amener dans un départage
de tous les dangers
allez c'est genre des stands yens bogo
indienne indienne
j'ai envie de te dire et donc les noirs
qui ont gagné le contrôle de la case de
4 pour le moment mais à tout le moins il
y aura qu il prend le 4.4 cavaliers d2
et les blancs qui vont revenir avec
foued 3 et 4 a eu 4 ou du fou g4 pour
échanger les fous deux cases blanches et
essayer de jouer sur cette case de 4
carats lieu 4 et f3 donc elle mais
lecavalier en 4l à une position ma foi
tout à fait jouable ici avec les noirs
car elle et j'ai trois attaques la tour
tour f4 et peut-être du dam de
maintenant pour protéger le pion alors
elle fait ces cinq direct l attaque et
alexandra kosteniuk est en voyage cinq
équidés de fer h4 est peut-être h3 par
la suite ou tour g4 pour s'en prendre
aux pions jets d'oeufs puis on prend des
six comprend des six il peut gagner à
voir pour concéder aucun coup 2e 4 un
moment
sonné pour venir encore accentué la
pression sur la diagonale h4 jouer
cavalier de tours g4 maintenant g3 qui
va être joué ça va prendre g3 et ça va
faire 4 à mon avis côté côté causé du
coup tours f8 on voit que toutes les
pièces noires sont en train de converger
sur le roi de bbc arabic sahara qui est
vraiment dans le dur ici les amis bis
araki qui a vraiment un problème de
développement fou prend ici ça à
reprendre peut-être même 2g avec l'idée
de faire f 5 3 7 tours g8 voient ya une
conversion ce terrible là des pièces des
pièces noires sur le roi en sachant
qu'une nul peut aussi finir la partie
pour pour kosteniuk qui a qui
al'avantage c'est probablement la
dernière partie du match ça a pris en g3
ça va reprendre et maintenant wife sept
tours à schwyz qui va arriver f5 aller
tour f1 il faut venir colmater tête avec
du cavalier f4 par la suite allait il va
falloir venir protéger pour pour bibi
sarah l'écueil des quatre peut-être
aussi pour cavaliers aussi c'est le fait
un échec dame f6 peut être échangé les
tables pour se soulager tour f1 c'est
bien joué mais là il ya aussi avoué 5
les amis qui prend qui qui fait une
enfilade
ah ça fait mal gaffe finalement de bibi
sahara dans une position qui était de
toute façon vraiment difficile et la
bibli sahara qui maintenant une position
complètement perdant doit s et c'est une
tour de moi qualité de - may hamm et
bibi sahara qui n'a plus aucune chance
ici même tourcoing f4 reprend des cinq
essais c'est game dans le match mais roy
e set elle va revenir alors attention à
une fourchette est toujours possible
aleph ont ramené peut-être le roi un
petit peu essayer de capitaliser sur un
cavalier 4 pas si mauvais mais c'est
bien joué que c'est new qui joue ce
pardon sur la colonne c'est seule
colonne ouverte et la tour qui m'arrive
ans et 8
les pièces blanches trop mal placé tour
est fait un tour ces deux et ça gagne
tout seul fr3 je crois mais tour ff2
tout rachat ouais le montre le roi mais
alors là le 3e 2e en dame
ça rentre tout seul de sa va rentrer et
tours d2 et ça rentre tout seul alors
que vanina l'a encore emporté
donc elle fait enfler le score qu'à 6 3
hélas chess quinn qui devrait remporter
cette partie
elle prend les pions le pion qui reste
pour le moment au 3 bis sarah doit
tenter d'envoyer mais maintenant menace
tourbe et 4 pour gagner gagner du
matériel tomber quatre affaires et tour
à 3 à l'écart et les h3 elle défend elle
se défend tant bien que mal encore un
mais là il ya le pion à 4 qui saute
c'est finir les gars tour j'ai trois
tours f 4k relief cinq échecs non elle
va pas faire ça comme ça pour prendre
trois à tourcoing f5 et on prend trois
pas vu mais bon c'est complètement fini
le match qui n'a plus un qui n'a plus
moyen de se retourner ici à moins d'une
déconnexion ou à quelque chose de très
improbable mais le cavaly revient mais
tour des trois cas et b1 tomber un
calice et 3b en dame
non elle fait même ça comme ça et ces
abandons et le match est terminé
matchs qui auront été plus serré que
prévu amir est musique zouk encore aller
encore un match serré de l'autre côté
anne amouzou que haut qui peut passer un
tour là avec les noirs contre le mook
joule aulas trois pions passé lié la
anna elle peut pas rater ça quand même
la joueuse ukrainienne séparé difficile
à rater ça quand même
j'ai du mal à imaginer les noirs ne pas
ne pas envoyer au moins un pion dans
l'en but mais on va voir on s'était on
avait déjà vu des choses incroyables
dans l'eure dans leur match il ya
quelques semaines avec des matches en un
raté mais là quand même le pion qui va
qui va filer même les pions qui vont
filer à l'est va faire tout rachète
lattes statu quo mais f3 qui va qui va
arriver c'est complètement finie non
mais attention
ouais voilà la tour qui passe en c2
c'est bien elle se met derrière le pion
maintenant moi j'ai trois menaces dame
f3 à risque elle peut se prendre un pas
tu m'entends
rendez 2 way autour autour autour ou
tour c'est un safem attend d'eux des
deux côtés et c'est musou qui
l'emportent les amis incroyable elle est
revenue de très très loin la musique
zouk pour éliminer mong-joon donc
s'arrêter aux finances même pas une
surprise mais à la vue de la physionomie
du match c'est là que le match a tourné
dont victoire du oui fans facile contre
nick cailloux valentina goût nina qui
écrase l'état aux ânes hamoudi tschopp
donc qui surprend dans le bullet mook
jul et qui revient et qui gagne le match
et alexandra kosteniuk qui fait qui fait
régner la loi est qui et qui bat bibi
sahara donc voilà pour les résultats de
ces premiers 8e de finale on va voir les
deuxièmes alors on suivra de nouveau le
match ça raconte irina croche troisième
speech est pour sarah et troisième fois
qu'elle rencontre irin accroche au
premier tour c'est bien c'est varié ça
change
avec aussi le match drogba val it à
thiais fouet c'est bien c'est pas
toujours les mêmes jouets ce qu'ils se
rencontrent au début donc on va on va
aller chercher
sarah est ce que ça joue je crois qu'ils
attendent maintenant malheureusement
avant les matches avaient déjà commencé
non elle a les matches aïe aïe aïe aïe
aïe aïe aïe avant ils aient commencé
directement c'est fini la belle époque
des matches qui joue un petit peu en
même temps pour pas que ce soit trop
long
ouais c'est pas de chance les amis on a
espéré un clé match soit déjà parti mais
sa passe est pas le cas ça joue pas
encore c'est terrible c'est terrible wen
en avance c'est la belle époque il
commencer les matches avant il est
commençait vraiment à 16 heures parce
que déjà que la compétition est longue
sur le temps ils essayent d'un petit
peut réduire comme ça mais ils sont dix
noms très mauvaise idée
ça doit bien durer bien longtemps bien
longtemps à lyon c'est une autre
philosophie c'est une autre philosophie
c'est terrible c'est terrible plus c'est
long plus c'est bon arf1 ça dépend de
quoi on parle taya non mais là c'est
terrible
tu vas te reprendre une demi-heure de
5,5 ha oui fans qui a gagné facilement
un conte running cailloux et 600 points
elo de différence comme entre les deux
voisins en feed c'est assez conséquent
c'est assez conséquent c'est terrible
c'est terrible les amis c'est terrible
de fait avoir commencé les matches
haïssons du rhin pourquoi en fait
pourquoi c'est la question
c'est quoi ce soir sur mon switch c'est
une des master class sur le contrôle du
centre dans les ouvertures à des quatre
à quoi ça sert d'avoir gagné le centre
on regardera quelques parties
c'est terrible
je sus non mais qu ils vont commencer à
14h à 16h30 je pense cette terrible
mais c'est dur
c'est dur mais bon ça repartir avec
quatre nouveaux matches or la seule
joueuse dans le deuxième tableau là qui
peut faire quelque chose
c'est sarah en fait tous les autres
matchs ne servent à rien toutes les
autres jouets sont déjà éliminés donc on
suivra le match de sarah qui est le seul
qui a le intérêt quelconque en fait ça
va être difficile
ça va être très compliqué
je vais mettre les cas moi je met les
calmes on voulait être maso de rester là
ouais ce qui reste là vous êtes maso les
gars vraiment voilà on va voir sarah
j'ai compris que vous étiez tous venus
pour ça ça date de la semaine dernière
quand même son dernier match mais mais
vous êtes quand même encore là pour voir
ça
je sors à l'instant même temps comme
d'havas quand même voyage sarah là on
peut déjà la m on va la trouver
alors là c'est pas ça son adversaire de
sa race et qui sait irina non plus c'est
beau que ce soit à chaque fois toujours
le même match moi je trouve ça
extraordinaire qu'on suive toujours les
mêmes matchs en fait ça c'est vraiment
du jamais vu quoi
mais moi j'en suis très heureux
comprenez moi moi ça peut être tout le
tout les mêmes tableaux les mêmes jouets
ce qui gagne à chaque fois et touchera
le plus heureux du monde
on va essayer de bien orthographier son
du premier coup
moi je l'espère hinxois le les mêmes qui
gagnent tout le temps le même truc tout
le temps et tout quoi ça joue sarah
jouent pour quel pays elle joue pour
l'iran mister p soit sa race sarrassat
datera des mâles charrier la joueuse
iranienne numéro iranienne très fort
joueuses un mathieu confirme le
prononciation de son nom de famille on
va pas demander à mathieu mathieu qui
est dans le dur un sahara qui a déjà
battu rinne a crush deux fois quand même
ouais iran iran le berceau des échecs
la percée du coup on va on va cesser
bercé par sarah dans ce match donc comme
vous dites de toute façon il n'ya même
pas avoir d'hésitation poursuivre
puisque tous les autres matchs ne
servent à rien donc on va suivre
vraiment le seul match d'une joueuse qui
peut encore se qualifier à l'événement
mais c'est beau en fait soit tout le
temps la même chose
c'est extraordinaire mais à moi je vois
de la beauté là dedans en réalité mais
je peux être quelqu'un d'un petit peu
spéciale pour ça je peux avoir
l'impression de pages peut voir du beau
sur du moche en fait je trouve qu'à un
moment donné en fait ça ça sente bien
beau si tu veux et n'hésitez pas si vous
êtes nouveau à à mettre un petit folle
sur la chaîne ça fait plaisir
radâmes has a un sens en arabe a du coup
elle même c'est pas mal en fait ça veut
dire quoi du coup c'est qu'elle porte
toujours le même voix le sahara avait
peut-être élan à plusieurs jeux pas trop
comment ça se passe
sarah irina ça faisait longtemps et abc
non mais le tournoi si vous voulez c'est
tu habites toi aussi tu vois la beauté
la danse c'est qu'en fait on est dans le
grotesque on est dans le ridicule si
vous voulez moi j'adore ces saisons et
dans le burlesque quoi tu vois on est on
est on est dans l'exagération de la
nullité quoi et je trouve que c'est là
que ça devient bon c'est si tu veux
c'est comme un bon nanar un bon nanar où
les gars n'ont pas fait exprès ou les
gars ont cru bien faire et c'est ça qui
est beau les gars c'est vraiment beau ça
c'est rare en fait il faut il faut se il
faut se délecter de ce genre de choses
dans la vie en à peu il y en a rarement
ya rarement des choses comme ça il faut
il faut s'en délecter parce que tu as le
mauvais film où les mecs ont fait un
mauvais film et ils n'ont pas vraiment
cru et tu comprends que ça va pas tu as
le mauvais film qui a été fait exprès ou
s'en rajoute est à nanard le nanar c'est
extraordinaire les mecs étaient dans un
délire ils ont pensé faire un truc de
bien mais les acteurs étaient mauvais
c'était mal filmé les scénarios étaient
nulles et sans vient génial cc c'est
terrible c'est terrible là là on est
vraiment dans ce scénario là on est on
est on est on est dans du beau si vous
voulez ils n'ont pas fait exprès en fait
et c'est ça qui est génial c'est qu'on
se retrouve avec trois fois le même
tournoi le même premier tour
c'est je suis la nuit du la nar j'en ai
entendu parler j'ai déjà voulu la faire
mais j'ai pas j'ai pas eu l'occasion
mais c'est quelque chose que que je
souhaite faire c'est extraordinaire et
c'est des choses qui sont trop rares
dans la vie
c'est une forme d'art en soi en fait
c'est quelque chose de différent mais
c'est quelque chose qui a une certaine
valeur et je dirais que la silla ils ont
réussi ça quand même
et ça c'est beau parce que c'est dur
parce que c'est dur mais à trois fois le
même match c'est extraordinaire non mais
du coup il ya aussi quand même un
intérêt
d'un point de vue sportif c'est qu'on va
voir syrie n'a réussi à à gagner un
match il risque irina va réussir et un
match parce qu'en attendant irina doit
être dégoûté de son côté donc voir ces
mêmes je pense que c'est écoeurant pour
irina en fait comment tu as perdu deux
fois le premier tour contre une joueuse
le troisième tournoi tu rejoues le
premier tour contre elle c'est du rhin
là c'est dur mais là en plus sa position
est vraiment dur à jouer parce que tu as
un vrai problème sur ce pion avec des
clous âge s'est pas très bien passée
l'ouverture pour pour irina shayk nadeau
un oui mais pas charte l'ado de 3,4 7h
est qu après ils ont voulu faire du
nanar je pense qu'on peut faire de l'art
sans en avoir l'intention
bo du rouble ou même et ça vient du ça
peut être un art simplement pour le
spectateur en fait un spectateur averti
peut voir de l'art
dans une chose qui n'était pas
artistique à la base comme tu peux voir
de l'art dans un joli nuage tu vois
s'était jamais arrivé d'avoir un nuage
qui avait une jolie forme ou un joli
paysage
c'est une forme d'art quoi ou un arbre
un tronc d'arbre qui peut voir pousser
de manière intéressante exactement ce
que dit monsieur petto à l'arrêt dans
l'oeil du contemplateur donc là vraiment
quand tu contemples ce tournoi avec les
yeux qu'il faut cependant bien génial en
réalité et c'est ça qui est beau c'est
grand et les jambes et là en fait non en
fait tu veux c'est la vision du billard
à quatre bandes de son moi c'est qu'en
fait ce tournoi est une perle
c'est une chance que vous avez de le
suivre c'est une chance c'est
extraordinaire c'est rare que vous voyez
des choses pareilles dans dans n'importe
quel type de sport c'est rarissime et ça
c'est beau [ __ ] et là je voyais en lui
ni ni ni ni ni ma profitez-en
profitez-en profitez-en les amis ce que
des choses comme ça vous en verrez très
rarement mais vous pourriez dire moi
j'ai vu moi j'ai vu cet événement
sportif et ça c'est beau bordel bon elle
a pas réussi à tirer profit de la
diagonale et du cloud âge là qui était
intéressant et maintenant cavalier va
venir en aussi s'il est bien placé il
chapeaute beaucoup de cases il contrôle
des cas qui protège le pion c5
ça peut être ça peut avoir tourné si
miley cyrus coupe de monde avait les
mêmes bugs mais [ __ ] c'est pas tu vois
c'est pas possible monsieur p soit dans
un sport confidentiel comme les échecs
on peut se permettre de faire des choses
pareilles
le foot il ya trop d'argent en jeu il ya
trop de gens qui regardent et tu
pourrais plus tomber dans du nanar pour
des milliards de personnes
c'est plus possible en fait il ya trop
de visibilité dans les échecs tu peut
encore réaliser ce genre de tournoi et
ça c'est beau donc radama charriait ça
veut dire servante de la charia paration
encore loin
donc et bonjour yoga dhalsim non mais
vous vous rendez pas compte de la chance
que vous avez en fait ça ça le problème
en fait c'est que le foot le tennis ils
peuvent plus se permettre de choses
pareilles
non ça remonte de la charia ça annonce
sa annonce la couleur
ah ouais non mais ça fait un peu peur là
du coup pour quelqu'un qui suit pas la
scène des échecs c'est des joueurs sont
professionnels oui oui c'est des
professionnels soumettre fit salut
marrant ton pseudo avec actes parlent
arabe racing est donc vous confirmez
écoutez vous avez attendu quand même
trois semaines pour nous est la
traduction du nom de sarah c'est
terrible à cette communauté c'est
terrible bon mais du coup est-ce que
irina peut enfin gagner un match
psychologiquement ça doit être dur mais
elle a jamais été dominé en vrai
rama chasse et un titre à l'époque comme
garde des sceaux par exemple intéressant
intéressant
bon là le problème en fait c'est que tu
as les pions sur noir talent adam 4 qui
chapeaute des trucs relou ta lecavalier
6 qui chapote fasse un peu de la merde
en fait
c'est quoi les scores 0 0
padam 3,5 si la dame prend 3 il va
horber 4 et ça va faire très très mal
vous voyez les pions les pions allèles
dam des noirs son mobile c'est des
mobiles est un des pions mobile on
appelle ça des mobiles est d'ailleurs le
mot c'est si vous réfléchissez aux
mobylettes sais je suis un peu mobiles
voilà ses cours de français mobylette du
coupure mobile il avance alors que les
pions de l'autre côté sont pas vraiment
mobile ce que j'ai 4 f 5 nov
c'est un peu bizarre quoi est-ce que
j'existe dans un match contre l on est
dans un niveau 2 sur un niveau différent
alors si on joue sur un échiquier réel
en partie longue
elles sont plus fortes que moi mais j'ai
existe un petit peu et si on joue en
blitz sur internet je suis plus fort
qu'à elle mais elle existe un petit peu
celle inverse en fait alors que moi je
suis vraiment spécialisés sur limites
sur internet et joie est un peu plus
fort calcaire match calme 150 poids
l'autre plus qu'elle et 350 surface
comme camille différence assez
substantielle pour espacer les côtés
d'irina pour ce match mais c'est vrai
c'est pas ce pas qu'on story qu'en fait
ça me demande de faire un changement de
caméra bon peut-être à la mi temps on
peut faire le changement de gamme chez
screen j'ai un score positif contre
jesse queen we sur beaucoup de partis
j'ai un sport positif et sheth queen est
plus forte qu'elle sur un score positif
aussi contre la gnose du coup qu'elle
est championne du monde
attention excusez moi d'avoir dérangé
l'idée c'est que sur ces 3 puis on prend
pions pour elle va vouloir faire dame
ses cadres pour faire un clouage fait
clouage contre clouage ou peut-être dame
b3 même malin
c'est la partie dame b3 même plutôt
comme ça sur dame prend b3 qui est prend
b3 mais sûrement je fais dam des 3 es tu
bien joué de la part de sarah elle
défend bien
attention ça peut être un peu chaud il
faudrait une commande qui donne la
situation des petits tanins nana et des
lots minimum correspondant ouais c'est
pas assez
c'est pas con intel table stéroïdes
d'ailleurs un truc c'est que toute la
république au mieux grandit plus il faut
de commande qu'il faut de commandes plus
à appuyer plus il faut acheter des
programmes il faut acheter des
programmes machin donc évidemment b3 bon
bah dam des trois il doit falloir faire
mais reste plus que 30 secondes c'est
dur quoi séduire dame des trois mois
j'ai un peu plus de mal en 3d web value
mitch après moi j'ai arrêté de jouer
sérieusement à 17 ans aussi j'ai pas
continuer aulas le landi propose un
super coup cavaliers ses 5 îles des fous
prend ses 5,2 me prends à [ __ ] en c5
ouais faut prendre ces cinq par dindane
france et 5 d'un pro d2 et s'est excusé
j'ai eu une hallucination d'amsterdam
des 3 way mécary c5 c'est bien joué mais
ça c'est hyper logique ce qu'elle fait
l'ordi aime pas mais c'est logique
puisque dame prend pions prends ton
pions passé il est tellement loin que tu
as l'impression que c'est très bien joué
bon après je vous annonce qu'elle va
perdre une nouvelle fois irina
réaction stand by sur l'échiquier réel
ouais si je m'entraîne j'aurais quand
même mes chances à défendre je sais pas
si j'aurais pu faire ou quoi mais je
défendrai ma chance après tu as on est
confiné donc c'est interdit donc faut
activer le roi alors une autre option c3
c3 g53 f5 pour essayer de gagner du
temps
ce qu'elle a en fait si elle atterrit au
f5 à laval a fait 1 2 3 4 elle aurait pu
faire un deux trois donc elle a perdu un
tempo et un thème tout en finale c'est
grave mais en train de faire mystifier
la selle qui va jouer la nuit lire in a
finalement 1 mais ça le problème c'est
que ça allait trop forte elle calcule
mieux qu'elle
donc même quand elle déconne en fait
elles s'en sortent et maintenant ces
mêmes sahara qui vous le garage et 4
c'est fini
non mais c'est incroyable quand même vu
la position qu'elle avait de base irina
si même ça elle perd en fait non mais si
même ça tu perds d'ailleurs alain rigole
enfin l'on rigole moi ça m'amuse pas
vraiment en fait si tu permets msata
vraiment aucune chance de gagner un
match contre ton adversaire tu peux pas
perdre un tel truc m
kim battant longue date et aux harkis
est plus fort en longues faut regarder
les lots 1
c'est simple c'est simple mais bon j'ai
pas je suis pas pro tu vois ma fille je
l'arrêté à 17 ans parce que je n'étais
pas assez fort donc après c'est une
question de savoir si les plus forts
cette question de l eau c'est pas mon
métier après tu vois donc c'est toujours
dur de de prendre mon niveau en longues
dans le sang soit
j'étudie jamais je fais pas de théorie
je fais rien tu vois donc je perds
compte beaucoup de monde c'est sur mais
bon après
suffit tchèque les lots généralement vu
que j'ai rejoué ça fait longtemps non ça
fait un an là d un parti que j'ai joué
en longue j'ai joué contre glen firent
glen flir ya un peu plus d'un an j'ai
fait nul je t'ai gagnant mais j'ai
déconné et j'avais gagné contre quelques
mecs assez bon bah ça se joue à peu près
à 2003 en langues j'ai joué douze ou
treize parties j'ai déjà dit ça mais
j'ai joué douze ou treize parties
j'ai joué douze ou treize parties j'ai
joué douze ou treize partis en longues
et ouais quand j'ai repris j'ai dû à une
perf à 23 30 tu vois je vois jouer à peu
près à ça entre 22 50 et 23 50 quoi ça
va être mon niveau ce qui est pas pas
mal ni bien ni mauvais on pourra pour
quelqu'un de l'amateur c'est pas mal ce
que j avais tu déjà mans longue oui je
n'avais pas joué beaucoup mais je l'aï
déjà battu l mais quand j'ai arrêté je
vais plutôt à 24 25 23 7 23 81 24 50
dans ce don ce réseau là on va dire 23
50 24 50
bonjour je veux pas pas mal quoi mais
bon du coup comme jouer mal j'ai arrêté
je jouais trop mal pour être pro et j'ai
arrêté j'ai déjà parlé plein de fois de
toute façon live bon elle va juste part
d'une pièce après g4 mais bon du coup
maintenant le seul truc auquel je suis
entraîné ces en bits sur internet c'est
le seul truc sur lequel je m'entraîne un
peu donc j'ai envie de dire des gens qui
vous dans ce dans ce même format faut me
battre faut battre à ce à quoi
c'est simple j'ai caché qu'on va avoir
fait c'est juste une pièce je comprends
je suis dépassée c'est quoi le problème
surgit 4 ok c'est kyle frange licata
frangé cadre d'un match 4-3 d1 dames
pranger quatre cavaliers f3 mais ok
c'est une pièce et yakari tour g1 qui
arrive je comprends pas pourquoi les
palets l'apprendre
c'est terrible c'est terrible
c'est terrible mais bon je pense qu'en
fait c'est tellement de la merde ses
cavaliers que j'ai quatre arrivées au
prochain et qu'elle peut juste rien
faire nirina dans la sauce way
non mais j'ai déjà expliqué soumettre fi
3g arrêté à 17 ans mais bon je te
réexplique vu que vu que là de façon
j'ai 4 va arriver c'est qu'en fait tous
les sports pro situation en faire ta vie
faut être fort faut rentrer dans le top
100 200 au pire et moi j'avais juste pas
les qualités requises
donc j'aurais bien aimé continuer à être
capable de rentrer dans le top 100 200
or c'était pas possible donc j'ai arrêté
et j'ai 6 kg s'est tu peux pas parce que
j'ai six sièges et quatre prennent quand
tu bouges de carélie adam prend 1,6 tu
es vraiment dans la sauce un ouais les
sports individuels c'est dur donc quand
t'as pas le niveau tu arrêtes 1 c'est
comme ça et merci à dsk l'ua qui suce
pour pour le sahb
eca et 17 un coude à quoi bon un
problème c'est qu'ils avaient dame prend
f5
pas possible non plus bon mais il faut
faire j'ai qui rassure j'ai katia quoi
temps je regarde juste leur dise ce
qu'il fait ça ça ça et maintenant ils te
dis qu'ici comme tu peux pas prendre
parce qu'il ya ça tu dois faire roi f2
il te prend il te dis que c'est pas
clair parce que tu t'es mal développés
mais ouais
après ça m'étonne pas à fâcher 4,5 et
une pièce tout de suite et de manière
claire précise et simple et tu te mets
dans la merde t'as déjà parlé en stream
de pourquoi tu a déménagé en russie
juste après ouais mais je ne ferai pas
forcément par les ans je peux juste dire
que j'avais des problèmes de santé mais
je n'en dirai pas plus en fait parce
qu'après c'est c'est un peu personnel ça
merlus c'est une des raisons qui a fait
que j'ai déménagé en russie à 17 ans je
conseille j'ai pu majeau position basse
que j'en ai déjà parlé stream et
j'aurais pu faire quelque chose entre
eux 24 50 et 25 50 on va dire pour faire
simple et c'est pas assez
parce que si vent dans le dos tu arrives
à 25,50 ça craint
b6 idée c'était d'ouvrir les lignes pour
attac allèles dame comme dans la
variante illustratif que j'ai montré
inquiet mais ça c'est logique un des
cats et le coût que je voulais vous
proposer le truc surtout prend des
quatre dames prend bekkat sur dame prend
des quatre tours des huit elle s'active
et je pense qu'elle va encore l'arnaqué
c'est terrible mais elle va encore leur
maquette
voilà maintenant dames promet quatre
échecs et vous allez voir qu'elle va
faire tourner la game tour des huit
après qui arrive et ça va faire très
très mal
carré des cinq autres options
je commande oui du coup une question qui
sont 2006 à l'époque tu considères que
c'était plus plus fort ou plus faible à
peu près pareil c'est plus fort dans le
sens où comme il y avait moins de
connaissances fallait mieux jouer mais
les demies non plus de connaissances
aujourd'hui que les 2000 à l'époque donc
l'un compense l'autre qui est des cinq
bon il va y avoir foule dame crambés
quatre échecs 1 qui va arriver a fini 6e
5e 5
madame prend bécasse à transpose en
réalité du coup dans dame prend b4 rock
qui a aidé 5
j'aurais peut-être fait autour des 8 du
coût mais bon elle va réussir à ramener
le cavalier en effet si c'est si elle
gagne cette partie je pense que irina va
être complètement détruit
psychologiquement et on pourrait
assister un massacre
mon cas plus f6 parce que le fou est
protégé mais peut-être cavaliers hf6
on a favorite pour le tournoi
je dirais kosteniuk
donc
cavalli eux deux on va voir fois-ci
soirée bombe
les blancs je vais vraiment bizarrement
maintenant ils ont du mal à terminer le
développement position est vraiment
bizarre et compliqué peut-être tour ses
huit maintenant sur g5 car l ie 8
carrillo 7 quel point ces six j'aime
bien aussi sur séché 5 a le temps de
prendre ses six prendre des 4es bouger
le cavalier mais là irina en plus elle
s'est mise très mal autant mais elle va
la perdre c'est évident annoncé l'autre
cavaliers qui va venir en d5
dames 5 f 6 tu reviens au pire
bon ça reste même à l'otan a à son tour
fait nul je pense non les noirs doivent
être mieux mais vu que t'as réfléchir
autant de temps tient qu'à elle fait le
tour s'est vite qu'à value8 que je
voulais faire de base
c'était mon idée première pour ça va se
jouer le gain c'est le mieux et d'amd
deux échecs 3g trois dames eu un mais
cavalier e set
on va prendre on va faire car il ya 5 ou
4 ans et 6 mai
ces morts qui a aidé 6 maintenant et ça
fait 2 0 mais quand tu survis ça dans un
match en général
en général ça signe un peu l'année
l'arrêt de mort de ton adversaire
winhouse et une âme sont pas de force
que james quinn au nom
non on peut switcher un autre huitième
bah écoute on a un peu regardés celui-là
quand même jérémy m'a pas ce que les
autres n'ont vraiment aucun intérêt dans
tous les cas en fait la sara c'est quand
même une jouer ce qui peut encore faire
quelque chose dans le tournoi toutes les
autres sont déjà éliminés donc l'intérêt
de regarder ça en fait c'est de regarder
quelqu'un qui peut encore se qualifier
dans les grands prix disons que les
autres en fait d'office qu'elle gagne ou
qu'elle perde ça ne change plus rien du
coup même si elle gagne le match en fait
il se passe rien
bon la sara
on sait pas vraiment il ya 2 0 peut être
son adversaire pour encore un peu
revenir mais je pense que qu'elle doit
être détruit psychologiquement
irina truc c'est dans les deux premiers
matches j'avais quand même pas mal
dominés donc tu peux te dire ok si je
finis mes parties ça va aller 4 rbds et
5 hir et la russie potencier
inqualifiable non
non non non
elle a déjà gagné un match long et irina
balle pièce qu'elle joue toujours contre
sara qu'elle perd à chaque fois au
premier tour donc non mais d'un autre
côté elle n'a pas eu l'occasion de jouer
quelqu'un d'autre ne versez pas de
chance non plus quoi
bon là c'est assez normal comme plombs
quand votre adversaire joue ses cinq
dans les gants vidame généralement la
réaction au centre avoir c'est eux cinq
systèmes de qualifs qui marquent des
points à chaque grand prix à la fin on
voit qui en a le plus voilà ça échange
madame des 4
alors quoi dame prend des 4 comprend des
quatre les tours 8
ou alors elle fait toujours 8 direct
soir la fille tori direct mais alors du
coup pourquoi les autres ont passé parce
qu'il ya déjà eu trois grands prix
jeremy mc c'est le quatrième est que les
autres joueuses peuvent plus se
qualifier à la fin en fait donc elles
peuvent même gagner le grand prix en
fait elles peuvent déjà plus gagner
c'est fini en fait mon âme g53 ff5 3f de
fous des trois raisons mais c'est peut
être mieux ça va me les 5
donc du coup en fait les autres elles
sont là pour décorer quoi faire il ya de
l'argent en jeu ou quoi donc pour aller
un petit enjeu mais j'ai eu l'air sinon
donc l'art wild 2 to re en fout des 3
ça paraît très fort très fort on va pas
avoir davantage mais gère ça paraît
juste logique
bon comme ça va aussi
c'est le quatrième et dernier grand prix
c'est ça c'était quatre fois le même
tournoi donc là c'est la dernière fois
qu'on regarde ce tournoi s'est de
nouveau les mêmes appariement s'étendent
à xv
non mais là irina qui a de nouveau une
bonne position alors si l on fait
quelque chose à 5-3 un peu faible étoile
s'est pas mal débrouillé tête h5 et vite
les maths du couloir et envoie un lion
royal en bullet ce qui passe pour pour
sarah pour irina pardon
ballan bulls qui passent leur bulle et à
ses passes et les amis bon h5 alors les
scores dans les autres matches on peut
lire on peut jeter un oeil quand même
une pique au nehru qui mène 2 0 contre
la guérilla
jeanne sayah qui mène un ennemi en demie
contre des six alors ça va jouer qui
savent ce qu'on fait c'est jouissif ou
la wii fan tu vas voir un match super
facile contre jeanne sayah guyane accord
un match difficile peut-être contre koné
roues sarah qui jouerait contre musique
zouk et kosteniuk contrat ricard est de
remettre la salle qui aura un match pas
trop dur ce sera ce sera ou s'ils ont
bien mis les trucs dans le bon ordre
non mais là une nouvelle fois un tour à
c'est un peu chiant pour les blancs pour
ça
à ce prix dit hunter qui est content on
aura les emotes des pieds pour avoir toi
non mais sarah qui est très forte en c1
est dur à jouer
donc
on a fait tous recettes je pensais pas
qu'elle ferait sa journée qu'elle
enverrait sur le roi se passe plutôt de
manière correcte
pour sarah
mais non elle est jeune elle peut très
bien jouer en langue elle est assez
régulière en fait elle peut faire
d'excellents résultats de mauvais
résultats mais peut faire des trucs de
ouf et ça joue vraiment bien juste là
dans ce tournoi ça se voit qu'elle
manque un peu d'entraînement ou quoi
sinon elle serait plus forte
ouais d'un f4 c'est bien joué cette
finale à halle doit être nul ça c'est un
bon coup ce que tu as l'impression que
tu as une mauvaise structure mais ton
roi en fait il va venir colmatée et tu
peux avoir des fois ci ce qui rôdent
pour reforcer le fou ans et 8 mai l'a de
nouveau elle va la gagner cette partie
vous allez voir je sais ni pourquoi ni
comment mais elle va la gagner
nava faire tu es 3f deux tours d2 foot
bouge tout rejet un g4 j'avais bien
organisé un truc comme ça si elle peut
elle commence par tours d2 d'ailleurs
mais je la vois bien organisé un truc
comme ça on va avoir un les amis
bref deux je pense à leval faire ça te
permet de colmater pas mal de trucs on
va un peu remettre les calmes peut-être
fou des trois toits hockey tour pro 3
dames pre3 prise de troie ça doit aller
mettre la tour en a3 j'imagine à madame
français 5 ou là j'ai complètement
oublié c'est une double attaque en vrai
c'est terrible fou prend des trois tours
prend des trois dames français 5 c'est
complètement terminée ah oui parce que
là tu perds b6 aussi derrière c'est
terrible sarah d'ailleurs on le voit
elle se cache le visage
ouais mais là c'est terrible ce qu'elle
a fait comment tu perds un truc comme ça
dans ces terribles
c'est pas en bo gerini massa encore un
système spécial son temps non en fait il
ya tout qui est mal dans ce dans ce
tournoi au niveau du format ya pas un
truc bien foutu
du coup non mais en fait c'est la
première fois que tu regardes ton à des
chèques ça peut juste dégoûté des échecs
en fait c'est pour ça que je le dis
c'est que ça qu un peu pour ça que je
préfère prévenir quoi sert il ya
quelqu'un qui tombe pour la première
fois sur un toit des chèques et qui
commente est qui et qui tombe là dessus
qu'ils commencent avec ça il peut
vraiment dire que les échecs c'est pas
bien et ok c'est pas de chance quoi
voilà c'est très mal joué encore de la
part de sarah qui se prend un clouage
bon c'était déjà fini mais elle enchaîné
les mauvais coups août et il va y avoir
2 1
non mais fabre de fabrice c'est vrai en
fait que le format il est mauvais de az
j'ose dire linverse en fait c'est vendre
ses ventes de ses ventes du mensonge
quoi et je veux pas je veux pas que les
joueurs amateurs qui tombe sur les
échecs la première fois ils se disent ni
les échecs font toujours comme ça c'est
vraiment nul
du coup on les revoit plus jamais après
je passe il encore des parties en cours
parce que c'est sûr que les 30 minutes
sont écoulées et je vais essayer ouais
ok je vais regarder avec le téléphone
sur le truc officielle pour voir si
encore des parties en cours bon allez
encore une partie en cours apparemment
ces algues aguerria attendue en bas on
va on va devoir trouver le pseudo il est
facile homme peu près comme vous le
voyez c'est pas non plus un match serré
il ya deux ennemis à un demi pour pour
un petit koné où finalement on a des
matches les plus serrées ça devrait
faire nul ça aussi
je suis que les candidats et les
championnats du monde puis de temps en
temps réel mais plus gay champion du
monde c'est aussi des formats bizarre
c'est fou fait c'est vrai que tous les
trois un des formats bizarre mais à foot
d1
non mais bon je veux pas je veux pas que
les gens qui tombent là dessus ils se
disent trop masson long c'est pénible et
tout parce qu'après si on va plus jamais
les revoir nulle part qui avait laissé
trois peut-être pour attaquer là est
peut-être après f 6 e 5
on va voir on va voir comment ça se
passe et fiction compter avec ces
terribles aux siens
d'une façon générale les formations pas
ouf comme on a pas de public on fait des
trucs pour les joueurs et comme on avait
deux formats pour les joueurs on a pas
de public ouais c'est un peu ça moi mon
p'tit quinquin
je suis assez d'accord avec toi dans la
formulation c'est pas que ça mais c'est
en partie ce après tu conseilles quoi
comme tournant à regarder en replay sur
youtube
[Musique]
dur à dire en vrai et c'est là des
championnats du monde de blitz mais on
n'avait pas les images du coup c'était
pas top top mais c'est sympa comme tout
reste c'est ton premier en général et on
aura petit doigt championnat du monde de
billes cdh rapide quoique on avait des
images cette année j'ai une bêtise ou
panne on les avait pas finalement on
aurait pu les avoir toujours sympa comme
format il faut y aller vite aussi un
c'est relou enfin moi je trouve ça relou
aussi peut-être fou des quatre ici pour
échanger essayé de faire passer laurent
b4 rapidement non mais les speech est
d'un point de vue général c'est sympa
mais faut tomber sur un bon match ouais
le tournoi sur internet par pays c'était
sympa aussi au quai ouest seniors omar
ça c'est vrai
ah mince ou lacaune airways fait
complètement attraper la le foin et
fuite il fait très mal elle a foutu tous
ses pions elle a oublié de défendre
elle c'est terrible vieira qui va
revenir
ouais non championnat du monde de
vitesse et de rapides en général c'est
le assez marrant vraiment dommage qu'on
ait pas vu les images pour le faire
enfin on l'avait fait mais sans les
images c'est moins drôle et oui la
nationscup c'était pas mal aussi c'est
vrai pour un premier tournoi c'est sympa
bon
le score on va voir le match qui peut
s'emballer
éventuellement si irina pouvait gagner
quelques parties mais non la nations cup
c'était bien vrai je suis d'accord ça je
suis d'accord
c'est un bon truc ça mais ce tournoi en
réalité il serait il serait pas mal
c'est juste qu'il est ils l'ont fait ils
ont fait trop sur la longueur 7 il
aurait fait sur une semaine il aurait
pris 32 joueuses
il aurait fait premier tour lundi sa
saisie en huitièmes de finale mardi
quarts de finale
il aurait pu faire mercredi jeudi
vendredi demi finales sur deux jours et
samedi la finale
il aurait pu faire du mardi au dimanche
du coup et ça aurait été assez bien ça
aurait été la même longueur que la
nationscup et c'était sympa sur une
semaine une semaine c'est bien pour des
tournois deux semaines c maximum car un
mois c'est trop long tu aurais pu
rattraper le coup en commentant avec un
gas gas et coûtent généralement dans les
audiences ça change rien qu'on soit un
ou deux donc on a décidé de pas de se
mettre à deux sur ce tournoi là et
apprennent en v6 faille commenta 2
talent et talleux t'avais vendredi et
dimanche et la semaine dernière avec
andré fabre du coup les commentaires à 2
vendredi et dimanche et la terre encore
vendredi record montrent en tous les
deux ouais le prévenu doit c'est qu'il
est très étalée tata beaucoup trop de
jours de jeu ce serait sur six jours ce
serait pas mal en fait en vrai problème
du format ont soit des matches qui sont
plutôt bien c'est la longueur c'est trop
c'est trop je suis là 1960 en blitz bas
quand il ya des tournois j'adore le 960
en blitz mais on a rarement bout du
rouleau
malheureusement malheureusement
ouais c'est dommage
un tour en mode coop en une journée
c'est possible oui ce sera organisée à
blanc une journée vrai faux de faire
jouer tous les tours en même temps
mais encadré commentateurs de vue la
toile mais j'écoute à l'état des duos
mais après c'est toujours ça me russe
une future mariée une question
d'audience aussi si tu payes une
personne ou deux personnes et a le même
résultat
c'est un peu problématique en fait c'est
à ça comme question alors des fois sur
des gros événements comme les candidats
etc
comme c'est un truc vraiment très
prestigieux ou quoi on met deux
commentateurs mais sur des trucs moins
prestigieux comme là c'est un peu
difficile mais du coup il met deux
commentateurs comme moi j'y suis pas
pour essayer de l'égaler le style non je
rigole fois c'est de faire un truc bien
robert matthey avec avec 100 m haies en
us comme ya beaucoup de gens qui
regardent leur lit sans dalle c'est pas
les mêmes sujets c'est même pas les
mêmes budgets c'est pas les mêmes
budgets
tu fais pas les mêmes budgets pour le
truc qu est-ce que pour que pour les
langues étrangères mais du coup grâce à
ses économies
vous allez avoir une série de vidéos
pour les membres diamant de fab du coup
sûr chess comme moi c'est vraiment un
rapport direct mais en gros il ya quand
même un petit rapport entre les deux du
coup au lieu d'avoir les commentaires à
deux là dessus vous aurez des vidéos
pédagogiques pour les bandes diamant sur
chaise comme c'est parce que tu prends
les mêmes caché que fabien andré a réuni
a avoué malheureusement non
malheureusement non c'est pas de chance
donc devant la chaîne soit une égalité
avec la chaîne reçoit et c'est dur
d'être égalité avec la chaîne russe du
fait qu'ils ont des joueuses russes dans
le tournoi et qu'il ya peut-être dix
fois plus de potentiel en terme
d'audience en russie au moins cinq fois
qu'en france et les espagnols aussi ont
un puissant une joueuse hispanique là
donc c'est déjà bien elles sont bien les
vidéos sur l'écossais dans les leçons de
chaises comme ouais c'est un bon
complément dany voulait pas lâcher un
peu de budget pour des événements
français
non je crois pas je ne crois pas je ne
crois pas alors attendez les matchs qui
ont repris ils font des événements
internationaux et puis c'est très bien
c'est très bien
c'est très bien non mais après je trouve
c'est plutôt légitime décès d'économiser
un peu de un peu sur les commentaires en
français pour avoir un peu plus d'argent
sur d'autres trucs plus intéressant quoi
mais ça va mieux après la fatigue dire
ouais mais hier j'étais surtout le
malade aurel donc forcément vrai nom
autant de secteurs de la chaîne russe et
ils sont deux sur la chaîne russe ou pas
je sais pas après mais après peut-être
ils ont plus de vabres et c'est ça
dépend un peu tu vois ça ça se discute
un peu avec les gars qui font de chaises
comme h un tueur je regarde pas vraiment
ils sont encore en pause la chaîne russe
s'emmerde part à la chaîne russe sans
rire de passe et ils sont repartis ils
ont pris deux de degas aussi
bah je sais pas moi je préfère je
regarde un peu combien con ce qu'on peut
faire et puis je discute un peu avec le
gars qui s'occupe des qui s'occupe des
débuts j'ai tout est joué un peu ce
qu'on peut faire et à et du coup ça
arrive quand je lui ai dit on peut être
économisé faire des choses pour pour les
membres diamant faire des vidéos faire
des choses un peu sympa le game a de
suite dit oui quoi ça dépend aussi ça
dépend de tout un chacun même disque est
ce que tu penses qu'ils aient mieux deux
affaires en france et c'est jordi web on
la laisse pitch assez féminin les gars
ça va pas attirer des foules ça vaut
peut-être pas trop le coup de mettre le
paquet là-dessus quoi sur toute façon si
je suis seule et à autant de monde qui
regarde que si tu as quelqu'un
généralement voire même moins parfois ce
qui est terrible il n'ya pas l'option c4
en l'air
non pas du tout il protège excuse moi
j'avais un coup de retard avait que
trois à six je me suis emmêlé les
pinceaux le puits ont été bien sûr
protégé par le fou fou baissaient pour
ces huit pays c4 et b5 par mon du coup à
titre perso je trouve c'est mieux
d'avoir à la place des arts des
commentateurs à deux pendant tout
l'événement et c'est avec vu le nombre
d'heures qui a d'essayer de le faire
comme ça en plus ça se passe très bien
et puis derrière d'avoir au moins
d'avoir du super-combiné a peut-être
qu'il prend ses quatre avec le
l'enfilade à voir j'aime pas trop
rentrer dans ces trucs là quand je vous
paye c'est si j'aurais fait aussi tu te
dis toujours ça peut marcher en longue
tu calcules mais en blitz
tu dis que tu vas te mettre dans le
problème tous seuls attention quand même
sarah un plus qu'une 20 et salue bacchus
xx
on va voir voir ce que ça va donner
non bref des huit d'ambea d'amd 8
c'est solide 1ère fois f4 non mais moi
ça me russe j'aime bien que présentée
avec fabre avec mathieu ou avec baky
c'était possible de le faire une fois ou
avec mazet ou quoi en fait j'aime bien
que présentée avec des gens qui jouent
vraiment bien aux échecs puisque je
trouve que c'est pertinent en fait et je
trouve que c'est vraiment intéressant de
discuter des chèques avec eux ont du
coup l'objectif quant à quelqu'un qui
coprésente voir quelqu'un qui apporte un
vrai plus en terme d'échec quoi c'est un
peu l'intérêt vlad tu vois c'est quand
même pas mal si l'on peut être pas eu
400 a besoin du coup des six marais des
si ça te fera de façon il fou qui va
venir en g3 pourront se mettre sur des
six donc ça c'est normal c'est un genre
de hérissons et ouais les candidats
s'étaient bien berly sandales faisait
carrément carrément
foucher 3 général de ce qui marche sa
mire l'uss et aucune us des reprises des
candidats n'ont pas encore jérémy mais
ouais bon après c'est les tendances je
m'en occupe pas trop trop perso si je
m'occupais des tendances juré que des
blitz en direct des échecs à 4 il y
aurait zéro master class et ce serait
ignorer foule de la musique en fête
non en fait je me mettrai à beats et je
mettrai de la musique et puis bah ça ça
c'est si je m'occupais des tendances tu
vois donc j'ai envie de te dire je me
tue m'occupe pas trop de des tendances
et de ce que enfin en fait je m'occupe
de voirie ce que fait quelqu'un je le
trouve bien est-ce que c'est du contenu
que j'aurais envie de regarder
est ce que ça apporte quelque chose aux
autres
si sur les trois à l'e3 ma réponse est
non je vais pas faire pareil même si ça
marche même si ça marche je m'embête pas
à faire des trucs parce que ça marche en
fait j'en fais un peu parce que tu es
obligé mais mais je me base pas trop là
dessus
ouais j'avais dans la tendance mais
toujours dans la bonne direction
exactement la dame ait fuité fous ces
deux ça fait mal ah non il même fou g8
ouais j'suis 8 d'arrêt vii matt même et
bien irina qui revient les gars
incroyable hein parce qu'après le début
de match et le fait qu'elle ait eu deux
défaites dans les deux premiers matchs
revenir un partout c'est quand même
assez incroyable en france et 4 c 5 rock
est ici 6 kills et trois assists à me2
des cinq fours b3 allez on va voir tour
d un qui va arriver
toujours la même variante savait était
d'âge des jalons après un parti avait
fait des cinq sinon il fera qu'elle
avait joué des cinq ici
ouais non je suis ce que j'aime bien
c'est quelque chose qui me fait pas je
le fais pas ouais je pense des 5 6 puis
on prend qui a et prend s'apprend et ça
pendant des 5 avec le fou elle avait été
quoi auquel avait été mieux
elle prend avec le fou tams et 7
elle avait été mieux avec les noirs
finalement dans cette partie et c'est
les blancs qui avaient gagné et ça lui
ben 1970 non mais ça pour irina une
nouvelle fois à mettre sa tour en 1 8
alors allez colonnes le fou en d5 pas
trop bien placé à la petite majorité
halal dames savent à quel alors dit de
faire qui a aidé quatre intermédiaires
pour prendre des cinq mais c'est dur
elle va pas voir ça je pense quoi que tu
étais obligé de le voir en fait
ok tu peux le faire dans l'autre sens ce
qui est des cinq qui est des cinq tours
des cinq tours dessin qui est des 4es kg
qu'athènes lester sûr qu'elle verrait
pas
c'était sûr c'est dommage qu'elle aurait
encore une bonne position et ça lui
cyril of trail c'est dur
elle peut pas prendre de cinq syllabes
et 7 en l'air à la fin on va faire gaffe
à g5 en l'air aussi mais qui va y avoir
une variante forcément pour réussir à
tout prendre parce que quand tu prends
des cinq on pourra reprendre du cavalier
protégé e set elle va juste prendre une
paire d'une pièce en fait mal mais c'est
dommage
c'est dommage en fête et sûrs h5 afu
prend 1,7 dans le premier set français
si ce qu'ils avaient promis cette fois
prend bessette
non mais là qui a aidé car j'avais pas
vu à lever cas ce que j'ai dit et le
redit mais j'aurais peut-être trouvé en
partie je ne sais pas mais je sais pas
peut-être j'aurais trouvé pas sûr du
tout mais le problème c'est que tu dois
trouver quand même pas la cage et 4
dames 4 ça doit tout de suite que ces
perdants là au pire il ya dame prend g4
qui on prend et fois je suis déjà qu'ils
gagnent une qualité ça va pas du tout en
fait
dur s'il est sur la côte ouest il est
huit heures du matin même à 8h du mat
scène bien joué c'est une bonne heure un
modèle français 3 es fou h6 g6 il faut
jouer ça de façon pas le choix tu crois
quoi elles pensent d'autres en fait
qu'est ce que tu peux faire de 9 francs
g5 ou là ok mais se faire mater là
j'aurais quand même fier la qualité et
jouer au moins prendre ces trois et se
battre là cavalier g5 qui on prend ces 3
comment tu fais ça padam hdaa me 4g six
dames h 4 h 5 e 6 forêt remarques
peut-être pas si ça visuellement c'est
dur mais c'est peut-être pas si simple
quelle voiture prendre ces trois c'est
obligé qu'est ce ça va c'est pas c'est
pas idiot ce qu'elle a fait mais il ya
aussi ceux ci qui fait me peut faire mal
ouais
l'annoncé c'est horrible tu auras les
trucs avec qui on prend au roi et je
suis damage 5
quant à lui enlève 7h six dames gestion
prendre un match cinq matches
bref si c'est bien joué mais ça va
gagner c'est terrible ce tarif pour pour
irina mais hockey qui a aidé quatre
c'est vraiment la callas ratée où là il
se passe quoi sur le pion prend 3 h la
suite d'un match 5 h 6 d'alger 6 puis on
prend g5 damage cinq matches le truc
thématiques que je vous ai montré
ouais comme ça c'est encore plus fort
j'ai six dames f6 matt mille fois plus
fort que mon truc en 40 coups ok mais
aller a qu'un point d'écart
et irina là c'est dommage avait encore
une possibilité
elle n'était pas si mal dans l'ouverture
lachance qui a validé quatre qui est un
coup marrant qui existe parce que sur
d'un point et lycées 2 du coup tu repars
en d1 et prendre ses trois prises ces 3
et pc 6 ou tu peux partir en hâte de
aussi d'ailleurs mais je crois qu'il ya
des quatre un couvent ici puis pour
irina non j'suis pour personne
mariage pour le suspense
bon sens et la position tout à l'heure
déjà sahara qui avait été malin qui a
été moins bien et qu'ils avaient perdue
alors je pour le beau jeu exactement
accus 451 de la compet chez pour que le
match se termine
excellence as virus l'ags les plus
drôles sont souvent les plus véridique
ah non mais je suis pour personne pour
le hors jeu pour un match serré en fait
puisque les autres matchs qui a plus
aucun intérêt sportif comme visé c'est
difficile à suivre et celui-là
s'il est serré au moins et un petit
intérêt quoi on va dire je suis pour que
sarah gagne dans un match serré sarah
serré salat serrer sa date mais sur moi
qui va gagner ça s'arrête
est-ce que puis on prend des cinq et un
coup je divague je pense que je divague
un bien fou prend que deux pieds prod
caisse était jouable mais ça aucun
intérêt alors tous rêvent d inde a mis 8
qui est peut-être maintenant se fait
plus de sens vous prend 1 2 qui est
prompt à eux deux ça a pas l'air
terrible non plus un mais la sara sont
les mieux mieux tiré
et du coup salam sall et ça veut dire
quelque chose ou pas vu qu'on a appris
que khaled al charrier cet égard de la
loi
du coup est-ce que salam sall et veut
dire quelque chose
je pense qu'elle va jouer mais fou
qu'elle joue plus vite en laye rina ça
veut dire rage donc à la fait depuis on
prend des 5 vous prend à 6 maintenant
pour la froid 6 toujours et tempo quand
même
ça les pieds sales mp ça les pieux
hockey et la d66 se passe quoi vous des
huit forcé
tout va bien et que ça joue bon on va
voir
d si ça faisait rien d'extraordinaire et
5 fu b5 d'accord faire bien pris pour
les noirs et la tour en c3 elle fait un
peu la gueule le pion va partir en d6
mais bon tant que t'as rien tant que
t'as rien de plus c'est chaud le quai
qui revient à eux quatre la tour en c2
tu te fais contre-attaqué sur f2 ce
temps du 1
witcher 2 qui découvre la supercherie
quoi c'est la troisième fois qu'elle
joue les deux ans ensemble c'est normal
c'est complètement normal bobby fischer
dans fouache 4 pour ces cinq ans et
c'est en train de tourner cette histoire
c'est le hasard la chance web bobby
fischer mais c'est pas les seuls qui
rejoint entre elles c'est parce que
c'est pas vraiment un tirage au sort ça
se joue aux lots et donc il se trouve
que là il ya eu ces trois mois c'est
terrible mais tout reprendre et cinq
classes et une pièce mais bon irina qui
est trop derrière eva cavalli eux deux
qui est français 1
c'est une tour qu'elle est à un poil
revenu dans le match et là elle reçut
complètement on va se remettre les
autres scores pour voir ce qui se passe
dans les autres matches amicaux nez ou
les autres matchs sont un peu serrées
mais comme je disais il joue plus pour
rien quoi donc c'est un peu embêtant on
va espérer aller encore une reprise
d'irina qui est quand même remonter au
score la dernière fois on va espérer
qu'elle puisse leur faire il reste
combien de temps dans la cadence
il reste encore dix minutes il reste
deux parties c'est terrible c'est
terrible
bon mais la bonne nouvelle c'est que ça
a peut-être faire une nouvelle victoire
pour ça je sais que vous l'aimez bien ça
du coup c'est bien si elle gagne on
pouvoir suivre demain
globalement crush dominent les parties
mais allait mener exactement c'est
exactement ça va dominer les parties cas
elle est un peu mieux
on va voir
bref un vrai fuite
bon c'est une petite finale un peu
insipide de base dans le sens où ces
traits symétriques les structures de
pions mais état absolument rien obtenu
avec les blancs très clairement c'est
juste égal et sajoo mais t'as rien quoi
donc une nouvelle fois dans l'ouverture
c'est plutôt bien place passé pour irina
d'après
faut se méfier de carélie c4 qui va
venir attaquer à 5
sarah soit quand même aussi mal préparée
pour une joueuse avec intel et l'eau
denquin
ses 6 500 est pris aux pions peut-être
cavaliers 5 qui a aidé trois maintenant
ça doit aller pour les noirs ou des cinq
pour empêcher kaïs et 4 et peut-être car
il ya eu 5
il faut qu'elle essaie de ne pas trop se
mettre mal autant tout cas les c'est de
rester assez assez compact on lit des
essais encaissés 4 un nokia e5 l'idée
c'est de l'empêcher
tout bêtement et devise est peut-être un
peu la case d3
mais à rennes de flou sur youtube wat
sage et j'y peux rien mejia stark
ça j'y peux rien du tout là les serveurs
youtube c'est pas de mon ressort
donc ils s'échangent ans et 5 ans ça va
plus ou moins ça va plus ou moins se
passe plus ou moins bien le client est
roi
why not
ça s'échange peut-être qu'un jour le
four 1 sera meilleure avec le carré les
clients b 3 ce peut être un petit un
petit plus à long terme pour les blancs
je prendrais plutôt les blancs mais bon
sait rien d'eux d'extraordinaire parce
que ce casque b3 pour le cavalier quand
même tu as ta classe quand même plus
agréable qui a été cinq essais 4
ouais et craché trop lente
haskell et nantes pascal calcul
lentement parce qu'elle regarde trop la
4 maintenant qu'un valet qui va reculer
ans et 7 et qu'elle prend à 5 sur ton
prend 1,5 à vous prend b4 et en plus
surtout reprendre du temps intermédiaire
il y aura ces sept en l'air à la fin
qu'elle prend à 5 c élémentaire elle le
voit pas mais fou 3 c'est bien joué
aussi un parce qu'il ya des fous p6 qui
rôdent maintenant way est en partie n'en
tenant s'arrête plus forte aussi
s'arrête plus forte de partout peut-être
qu'elle se prépare plus sérieusement en
lantin hockey prend 1,5 et surtour à 8,6
à cavaler ces six échecs et c'est
peut-être cinq échecs pour le piège non
à peut-être cinq maintenant et a pas de
casse pour le roi tu venger six f-16
actuellement arrive cinq les cavaliers 7
fallait angers 5 et ça fait 5 de voix le
score qu'il ya un peu trop sévère à mon
goût la sara qu'il ya une trop
facilement
peut-être qu'on va aller voir le match
aller 2-2 hickory peut-être espérant que
soit plus intéressant
là malheureusement c'est quasi terminée
on va pas se faire de mal
on va un peu aller voir cauris quant à
double malick sy quoi c'est une caisse
en double filles en quête au contre un
double enquête aux voies sont tenus une
estonienne ce truc là je regarde
j'analyse des coûts en fait sans une
estonienne des variantes avec g3 fou
j'ai deux je crois
donc 1
on va voir ce que ça donne ici tour à 7
qui est pas mal joué tout cas il ya
égalité et c'est déjà quelque chose qui
fait plaisir trois sets ça protège le
fou ça prépare peut-être que des
arrivées de la tour sur la 7ème et des
dames à 8 aussi qui rôde et donc sort je
ferai une master class à 20h30 on vide
sera peut-être un peu avant même si
maintenant ils ont encore rallonger les
les matches et c'était c'était censé
terminer à 17h30 tous les jours et vous
voyez c'est arrivé plus tôt à 18h 18h30
donc on verra j'ai moins de g ça
m'enlève encore grosse demi heure de
repos mais ça me rajoute d'une
demi-heure de commentaires donc c'est
assez durs envers des heures suprême du
coût des heures bien sup
voilà va faire prendre 2e je pense
qu'elle va jouer contre le pion aux cet
arriéré mais elle peut aussi prendre de
ces jeux pour qu'il y ait des deux qui
essaient ktef 4,5 mais je pense prendre
2 est assez standard
ouais elle a pris 2 et tours 1 c'est
hyper standard façon ça gagne un tempo
sur le pion aux 7
on va voir ce qu'elle fait
dit expérimenté corps y aller elle est
pas si âgées dont corrige crois qu'elle
est jeune cory je crois qu'elle est
assez jeune cory roquettes pour bloquer
le contre jeu 27 ans et j'avais été plus
jeune encore bon allez encore quand même
très jeune en 27 ans ces jeunes six ans
de moins que moi je suis à fond
voilà le truc logique c'est de mettre la
tour en 1 3 et l'autre en vain
mais peut-être des karellis et 4 c'est
pour ça qu'elle a fait comme ça mais
juste la tour si elle est en 3 être
couvrir et l'option le carré en bep cap
d'ail fait rien mais abdul malik elle
doit avoir quoi 18 19 ans
je veux ce péruvienne à la fameuse école
péruvienne d échec serait capable de
bons joueurs péruviens
il ya une grande et ats-unis gars il ya
corrie le frère du coup de daisy et a72
hickory qui joue bien il ya martinez
alcantara ils ont quelques quelques bons
joueurs les péruviens bonne école des
joueurs valeureux c'est péruvien
tous ces trois tours ici
écarts et les g5 d'accord
alors quand est-ce qu'on perce avec les
blancs elle s'organise petit à petit
remettre la tour en trois sets pas idiot
il faut en d1 pour bien blindé là je
vois juste crush qui voudraient
caméscope est contente
non spécialement j'ai peut-être qu'elle
revient un peu dans le match
mais pas du tout
tour 3 elle va ramener cavagnan h3c à
partir produits qu'ils avaient les f4
food and à me2 je pense le plan a l'air
plus ou moins claire bref ou des reins
jouais bien je vais protéger le le pion
b3 et fou prend à 5 menaces devant
revenir en b 4 dames dès maintenant
3 je ne comprends pas trop l'utilité
cet aveu cavaliers géant à f3
kiev 4 d'accord
cinq peut-être carré dh 3 kg 5 bon je
regarde juste qui se passe dans l'autre
match pour me faire une idée
syrine à gaza là en fait elle revient un
peu quoi elle garde une chance
bon c'est le suivent deux parties en
même temps la frange et quatre ans j'ai
catane est le cavalier angers 5 le
retour il faut prendre tout reprend et
peut-être d'un f4 maintenant dame g4 a
fait tour 3 elle défend et maintenant
dame franges et cassel va gagner
tranquille un bonne partie 1 de daisy
tout en contrôle pas ses atours en e2
super bien joué en 2 à 0 et 4-4
maintenant elle va encore en gagnant là
pour mettre son quart à lyon b5 et tours
sète et ça rentre tout seul un parti de
hockey sarah salat qui a gagné le match
il ya 6 2 donc c'est fini
donc en gros là il ya plus qu aucun
match avec un quelconque intérêt
on va se suivre du coup à celui là
jusqu'au bout daisy qui joue quand même
bien se fait plaisir
peut-être qu'avec des six cavaliers au
8ème tour c'est ça pour ces huit noms
c'était mignon ça va gagner russie un
petit à petit ouh là là elle donne une
pièce en a c'est terrible ouais c'est
terrible oh là là c'est terrible
heureusement que la finale de pions
gagne assez facilement en plus
ou pas
non c'est plus gagnant au nom comment
elle a pu rater ça avec les blancs c'est
élémentaire maintenant à faire annuler
le roi valet dans le coin et on peut pas
gagner avec un pion à a quand même
quand même c'est dommage le match va way
veulent à la mi temps mais a non mais le
truc c'est que ça faisait longtemps que
la position était gagnante et et la
finale après et et puis si simple à
gagner il fallait jouer plus bon
maintenant on a perdu la partie mais je
pense si j'avais joué en beats avec peu
de temps j'aurais fait ça et là j'aurais
pas fâché que j'aurais fait g5
mais j'aurais pensé me simplifier la vie
1.5 trois des quatre rois des 6,3 ck3
ses 6 h 5 puis on prend g6 j'aurais
pensé me simplifier la vie en faisant ça
pour jouer avec f5 après prendre prendre
mais bon c'est pas si simple avec les
purs a4 et h4 en vrai elle n'était pas
si simple à gagner cette finale
le plus simple serait de faire trois des
quatre peut-être en fait trois c4 est
allé chercher le pion là bas et jouer le
pion h après laon vrai n'était pas si
simple à gagner cette finale
bon avec beaucoup de temps c'est simple
ce que tu peux calculer
elle a du coup il fallait évidemment et
partirait caisse a gagné facile en fait
quand même mais bon je peux comprendre
que t'es pas eu la lucidité de le faire
ouais pas si simple à gagner celle-là
donc on va faire une petite pause et on
vient pour le bullet dans dans trois
petites minutes
merci de suivre les gars a tout de suite
je repasse la partie en entier terre
pour la peine pendant la pause
à
l'eia ça y est les dix dernières minutes
de jeu la danseuse dans ces matchs alors
on va suivre le match 2 des easy contre
contre moi je vais essayer on va essayer
de récupérer vite les calmes
c'est une première cape et on va
récupérer la deuxième place et mettre
les noms rapidement d easy cauris on
suivra de son côté et de l'autre côté on
va écrire jeanne sayah nous écrit elle
nous excusera c'est elle même qui écrit
que son prénom long métrage and syria
doumali que c'est pas il ya des yade est
double elles il ya des trucs on peut se
planter
on va pas s'embêter on va être un faux
l'eau sur des easy a et ça vient ça
vient de commencer les gars donc jeanne
sayah qui a les blancs mince on veut
aller on va suivre de l'autre côté on va
tourner l'échiquier c'est égalité pour
le monde dans ce match d easy avec avec
les pièces noires est là elle vient de
rater un gros truc un an la partie
précédente est maintenant dans cette
partie c'est jeanne ça ya un qui attaque
de tout de toute sa force sur sur la
droit puis on prend g4 dame prend g4
pour s'en prendre aux pions g7 et même
si c'est les blancs qui ont le mauvais
fouet les noirs le bon fou il ya quand
même un gros avantage des espaces il ya
le pion b5 en l'air mais il ya aussi gf
et dames g4 qui est entend aller jeanne
sayah qui prend en b 4 cavaliers e4
lecavalier qui trouve une belle case
notre cavalier blanc qui revient en d4
et qu'ils retapent le sur le pion aux
six les noirs qui joue le fou ans et 5
pour jouer sur le clouage les blancs qui
enchaîne avec une dame en f3 et
peut-être on peut échanger à tout moment
en d4 on va voir allez les blancs qui
joue tout rejet de qui défendent le pion
b2 qui vont préparer l'arrivée du tour
engins pour doubler le long de la
colonne chez les noirs qui met la tour
eiffe cette tour g1 qui arrive si on
prend 1,5 à 3,5 qui peut tomber à tout
moment la dame qui va peut-être venir
jusqu'en h3 pour augmenter la pression
sur f5 peut-être plus on prend un f5 en
premier voilà pour forcer le prend
et damages 3 comme ça après fou prend au
fond il y aura peut-être des os xi skies
qui traîneront non cb4 qui est jouée
prend des 4 prend des 4 tours 6 force et
un pour empêcher le 6 et ouais non elle
le fait pas mais là il ya eu six qui
tombent ou là fallait absolument
empêcher ça puis on prend f7 et ça va
rapidement faire 1-0 pour pour jeanne
sayah tout reprend g6 ici semble déjà
être une grosse option pions prendre
tout reprend qui menacera qui menacera
beaucoup de choses là on menaçait fuite
dame
allez on va faire quoi côté côté jane
sayah ondam quand même dame premières
fuites damas cet échec et dame prend des
4 ouais c'est bien joué la côte est côté
kazakh la petite tactique qui fait du
bien et ça fait 1 0 déjà dans ce premier
dans cette première pour cette première
partie ça fait 1-0 dans la cadence
bullet et ja sayah qui même un petit
écart il ya déjà un point d'écart après
la première la première ronde entre ces
deux joueuses 5 jeux à 4 pour pour abdul
malik et la joueuse péruvienne noms qui
jouent un double enquête au avec les
pièces blanches qui met le pion en c4
qui va préparer l'arrivée du cavalier en
c3 pour mettre la pression sur des cinq
noms les noirs qui ont pris en c4 qui
ouvre un petit peu ce fou j'ai deux mais
le fou g2 qui encore bloqués par les
pions bessette c6 qui met vraiment une
grosse défense contre lui et il va
maintenant falloir réussir à faire péter
ce verrou peut-être via cavalia quatre
cavaliers ces cinq peut-être ya eu
quatre des cinq on va voir ce que la
joueuse péruvienne décide de jouer la
jouer ce péruvienne qui jouent eux
quatre fous j'ai 4 ans
donc attaque la dame alors que quatre
prenait le contrôle du centre et le fou
qui revient aux six pour taper sur le
pion b3 comme on l'avait prévu
le pion blanc qui part en dessin qui va
reprendre en dessin qu'elle va reprendre
avec le cavalier oui ça va échanger en
d5 échangés selon le long de la longue
diagonale
excusez moi et léo la cave a lieu trois
ouhlala prix en g7 en premier qui avait
lieu trois intermédiaires en ça fait mal
les amis la joueuse péruvienne qui n'a
pas vu ça et maintenant après pions
prend il ya dame prend trois échecs
puis roi prend g7 il semble que abdul
malik fasse mal ici quel point f1 prise
f1 ça va reprendre en b3 et peut-être
même f6 alors la f6 d'abord pour éviter
le mât temps j'essaie depuis prises en
b3 ses qualités pion de plus maintenant
pour la joueuse kazakh la jouer ce cadre
là que casaque bleue donc sur le drapeau
qui réussi à faire l'écart la tour qui
arrive en 18 la tour qui va arriver en
d1 maintenant c'est carrément les blancs
qui vont se faire attaquer dans l'oeuf
une enquête au bras c'est le monde à
l'envers ici c'est pas les c'est pas les
blancs qui ont le contre je sais les
noirs qui ont les compensations pour la
qualité de plus la dame qui va prendre
en b1 et ouais un petit coup de ton des
huit bêtement et fois h3 et ça va gagner
tout seul tour c'est 8 encore plus
ambitieux pour jouer poussé quatre
peut-être plus fort
mettons des 8 va faire le tapin fois je
crois en échange les dames et on va
gagner le pion à tranquillement avec la
tour la fois h3 forcerait le retour
d'une dame en bessin qui échangent des
dames et c'en est fini des zee qui a
raison d'abandonner rapidement pour se
remettre dans une partie ya peut-être
encore le temps d'en faire deux et
d'égaliser mais maintenant on n'a même
plus le droit à la nulle côté péruvien
la moindre défaite la ferez passer par
la porte même la moindre nul a laissé
une défense française qui a joué par la
péruvienne qui rendent hommage aux
français qui suivent son match la dame
qui est venu en d2 la prison ses cinq ça
va être repris par le cavalier c'est
bien jouer maintenant grand roque à
éviter de la pousser ses quatre pour b 5
c 4
les noirs qui met la dame ans et celles
qui vont mettre le plan b 5 b 4 les
blancs qui cache un peu leur droit et
qu'ils vont envoyer g4 maintenant et f5
h4 ça va partir avec du cavalier h un
guide à me2 du damage ça qu'on va aller
attaquer petit à petit la le roi l'a
pris en c5 elle mais ils font en d3 on
me now va commencer à mon âge c'est des
fous proches sept cavaliers g5 dame de
damages 5
ça va arriver daisy qui est en
difficulté dans ce début de partie une
nouvelle fois abdul malik qui semble
avoir fait la différence dans ce match
maintenant le cas
et qui vient vers eux deux verges et
trois vers h5 peut-être pour revenir ça
sacrifiant g7 ouvert f6 pour venir se
claquer où le cavalier qui peut venir
angers 5 les noirs qui sont en
difficulté f5 elle veut tout tout bloqué
à la tour qui prend f6 lecavalier qui va
venir angers 5 pour attaquer
éventuellement le pion à cette annonce
et g4 qui est joué maintenant ça va
enchaîner avec g 5 h 5 h 6 avaya les
cavaliers g5 aussi une option attaque
attention le plus avec 4 qui est
attaquée f5 cavalier e 5 ça va reprendre
cinq prix de 5 g 5e 6 maintenant qui va
qui va partir c'est la joueuse la
joueuse kazakh un qui est en train de
faire une sacrée différence ici le pion
qui va arrivant à m6 qui va ouvrir
toutes les lignes devant le roi adverse
l'aller le pion qui part en exil jeune
zahia
il ya aussi dame prend b4 qui traîne
mais on comprend aussi c'est un petit
peu étonnant qui réactive complètement
les pièces noires et qui laisse
peut-être une ouverture à adhésif corrie
dans cette partie y aller le fou qui
vient au g4 alors maintenant comment on
réagit way tour f1 c'est logique on se
déclenchent les noirs qui vont qui vont
devoir trouver un coup ici d'attac
peut-être à 5 pour commencer à envoyer
les pièces de l'autre côté dont elles
mèneront h à 8 h 6 g6 qui va être
provoqué non tours.fr en premier c'est
sûr échec donc elle force son point f 1
maintenant on imagine plutôt joué j'ai
six pour couvrir les cases blanches non
elle ne l ignore complètement et
maintenant peut-être g6 du coup pour les
blancs qui n'est pas jouer les noirs qui
vont reprendre du fou en g7 et les
blancs qui vont envoyer probablement g6
attention à daisy core i d i qui n'a
plus trop de temps l'âge et si ce qui va
arriver tourache 8
non c'est pas toujours pas joué
peut-être dames trois cavaliers c'est un
coup un petit peu étrange pour moi mais
elle prépare peut-être l'arrivée de
l'adamant angers de cauris qui a mis la
dame af set pour réagir la dame qui
repart vers e6 est peut-être maintenant
cavalier b3 cavaliers ses 5 1 qui peut
revenir mandat m de haut pour damas est
c'est bien joué les amis au la dame qui
va partiront à 7 sur échec le pion à 5
qui va tomber
jeanne sayah qui est en train de se
gagner le match aller en train de se
gagner tout seul
elle est en train d'aller se le chercher
d'impro à 5 maintenant dame prend des
cinq peut-être pour raser tous les pions
et menaces dam des quatre échecs
peut-être dans certaines variantes avec
des doubles attaque la dame qui va
partir en d4
peut-être en h4 on est en train de vivre
la fin du match les amis tour h1
peut-être le retour g6 maintenant qui
part h 6
on sent le ko là il ya du ko dans l'air
côté côté péruvien oldham même si ça les
change les dames finalement décision
plutôt étrange mais pourquoi pas ça
échange la tour qui revient aux seins ça
joue un peu sur le clouage fouet si si
ma mémoire du fleuve 5 j'imagine
ouais c'est vrai que là nul gagne le
match donc ici pour prochain iam est
quand même à elle avait plutôt la tacc
et daisy corrie qui revient un petit peu
cavalier agissant au nom cavaliers h5
fourchette qui a eu 3 et 6 et g7 hawkeye
prend 1,8 lie à tous qu'il tombe et c'en
est terminé des espoirs péruvien dans ce
match jeanne sayah qui s'imposent
elle mène de trois points il n'y a plus
moyen de remonter on va aller voir le
score des autres matches pour voir que
koné roues koné roue peut encore se
faire remonter par par guerrilla on va
tout de suite filets côté indien les
amis allez on part du côté du gange côté
gauche qu'est ce qui se passe
olga guerrero qui est un pion puisqu'il
va pouvoir peut-être nous amener vers
des des partages de folie on va voir
mais là ça va ça va prendre en b6 est
complètement finie et guy arias qui va
qui va nous amener vers le départage
tour pro d2 et c'est fini et c'est
terrible alors est ce qu'il reste encore
une partie ou pas on va le voir mais
sinon ça va nous offrir de superbes
départage les amis dans ce dans ce
tournoi alors est-ce que ça a joué ce
qui en est encore une opa ça semble
jouer les amis partis décisif à 6
partout alors les scores on en est où il
ya six quatre drones à 20 arica qui a dû
gagner le match
sarah qui l'a emporté abdul malik a
emporté maintenant voilà partie décisive
donc dans ce match entre koné ou koné
roux ex numéro un mondiale excellente
joueuse qui a qui a accouché il ya pas
si longtemps d'un d'un enfant est qui et
qui est revenu là qui revient au top
niveau notamment au travers de ses
performances dans les grands prix fidh
qui pourrait qui pourrait de nouveau la
mener vers un titre de championne du
monde qu'elle pourrait obtenir pour pour
la première fois donc le cavalier qui
pourrait venir maintenant ici à eux cinq
côtés m piccone roues pour jouer sur
cette belle case et sur une belle
activité vers vers les droits c'est très
thématique cavaliers qui arrive en a eu
cinq des têtes du damage 3 damage 3 qui
va arriver x 3 elle veut échanger les
fous de cases noires même si c'est le
mauvais fous ils pouvaient s'ouvrir le
long de la grande diagonale koné rookie
échange la dame qui va arrivant à 3 et
maintenant il va falloir défendre le
pion des cats qui est attaqué par le
cavalier c'est chose faite après qu'ils
avaient pensé si souffrance et 6
maintenant peut-être que l'autre
cavalier va revenir en f3 puis on a eu
cinq ans il passe par ben c'est 3 à la
bac qui j'ai envie de dire dame qui va
revenir en hausse est le cavalier qui va
revenir en c3 et peut-être des dépenses
et 4 arriveront pour ouvrir le fou de
cases blanches le long de la grande
diagonale et c'est pour cette raison
comme piccone rouge ou c5 maintenant il
va pouvoir y avoir un changement de
structure de pions après des français 5
des français 5 y aura peut-être eu 5
puis le 4 pour les noirs donc peut-être
que tout reprend va être jouée par koné
ou non elle sls l'avancé des pions
centraux et elle va vouloir avancer
allèles de son côté ça va être un combat
remarquable ici les amis entre les deux
joueuses le pion qui vient à eux quatre
mais qui ne menace pas un pion prend des
trois cependant le fou qui est quand
même venu on assiste pour attaquer la
tour la taupe qui vit en belgique qui
attaquent b4 mais le pion va sûrement
avancé en bessin qu attaquer le fou le
fou qui par le pion qui avance ans et
c'est ce qui va avancer ans et s'être
les amys option qui semble inarrêtable
alors peut-être c6 le fou qui va partir
en gkf 3 qui va rejouer sur le clouage
le fou qui va partir au h5n1 dans ses 7
6 8
olala la chaîne de télé qui ce qui ce
qui ce qui serait à lui blanc sur la
casse c'est 8 et maintenant tu me
connais roux qui semble avoir un
avantage quasiment décisif il va falloir
jouer tourbe et ses 8 pour les noirs fou
prend ses huit tours prend ses 8 et
maintenant peut-être qu'à valises c3
pour venir jouer du cavalier prend des
cinq s'assemble ça semble logique tant
elle fait ch et 4 elle s'ouvre un peu le
droit c'est toujours dangereux en bullet
fou g6 qui va venir et peut-être f4
maintenant pour jouer l'enfermement du
fou ou alors j'ai cinq je ne sais pas ce
qu'elle décide où il joue le coup à fond
quatre cavaliers qui va revenir en c3
mais c'est extrêmement dangereux tour
français cette dame française f5 f5
direct joué les noms les blancs qui vont
avoir une tour de plus mais les noirs
qui vont avoir peut-être un petit peu d'
attaque sur le roi gaga qui doit sauver
sa vie 1 pour rester dans ce match c'est
la dernière partie l'ultime il y à cul
nu à l'appui temps elle a plus que deux
secondes 8 la joueuse russe
et là il a tout repensé cette dame
français cette tour prend des quatre qui
semble très fort elle a pris primer la
tour c 7 pour des quatre ça va faire la
tour la tournette de plus les amis oui
mesdames c'est un tour d un on couvre
tout ça va être difficile pour le gag
herria de revenir le cavalier qui va
venir en c3 qui va intervenir sur le
pion aux 4 gears ya qui n'a plus de
temps peut-être un cavalier des cinq ici
un pour provoquer les échanges dans
tournez un jouet dame e5 avec peu de
temps sur sur la pendule un garrot gaga
qui tombe c'est terminé elle n'a pas
réussi à mettre le coup d'accélérateur
et un pico nehru qui s'impose dans ce
match 7 à 6
très très bien joué de la part de la
joueuse indienne qui ira voir le second
tour et vous la voyez pas la caméra mais
le gaillard yaki ceux qui se tient la
tête entre les mains qui a perdu ce
match un pic au nez rouge qui sera donc
en quarts de finale de cette quatrième
étape des grands prix fidh
allez il reste peut-être encore harry
qu'à arica peut-être ça joue encore de
son côté alors son pseudo c'est quoi il
va falloir le trouver ces élégance rixe
une joueuse très dangereuse dans ce
format qui on se rappel l'année dernière
avait réussi à éliminer la joueuse
française maryse ce bac mais son match
et la russie termine et il semble que ce
soit le score final qu'on est à l'écran
6,5 donc qualification de d'arica
apparemment drones à vali contre contre
ta tiers je vois encore les jouets se
connecter c'est pour ça que je ne sais
pas mais il semblait il semblerait
qu'elle soit qualifiée en tout cas dans
les autres matches sahara qui a gagné
lui 3 koné ou 7,6 donc et jeanne sayah
7,4 y aura peut-être 7 5
mais c'est de toute façon assez
anecdotique
j'ai l'impression que les scores sont
figés et donc on aura des huitièmes de
finale donc un joli 8e de finale 1-1
rica qui jouera contre kosteniuk sarah
contrat la musique joue ce sera tendu
qu'au nez rouge contre valentina ce sera
aussi un match difficile
et oui fans à mon avis quand elle sera
grande favorite face à jeanne sayah
abdul malik mais tout ça pour le voir il
faudra se connecter
ici même au même endroit à partir de 14h
30 les amis
ah les deux corées de corée qui ont bien
joué dès y éliminer tout de même de quoi
y ait de bons joueurs mais à m'éliminer
voilà pour pour les scores des matchs
les amis j'espère que vous avez aimé ce
que vous avez vu n'hésitez pas à suivre
ma chaîne par ce perso vous avez le lien
juste en dessous on se retrouve ce soir
vers 19h 19h30 pour un peu de blitz et
20h30 pour la master class et je vous
dis merci merci à tous ciao ciao à ce
soir et à demain sur cette même chaîne
et qui peut encore faire la grande
finale pour répondre à condition gunino
sahara ou ifan et alexandra kosteniuk
merci encore d'avoir suivi
ciao